e
ladies and gentlemen before we get
started I just want to let you know as
as I understand it um uh our legis our
legislative Services office is setting
up an overflow room where uh people that
uh you know if people that are standing
would rather sit I think there's there's
going to be an overflow room where
you'll be able to hear what's going on
so it's up it's entirely up to you
whether you want to take advantage of
that and we'll start
shortly
e
e e
all right I'm going to uh call I'm sorry
I'm going to call the house Judiciary
Committee to order and as the first
order of business I'm going to rep
recognize representative Perez to lead
us in the Pledge of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
thank you representative
Perez before we get started um uh on the
business of the day ladies and gentlemen
I'm going to recognize representative
Andress who wishes to make a state good
morning Mr Speaker good morning citizens
that are here today good morning
colleagues I have something to say and I
need to apologize to everyone it was
brought to my attention a couple of days
ago that last week when I presented
House Bill 114 when I was finished which
I did I returned to my seat here and I
should never have done that because
that's against the rules so I apologize
to every citizen and all my colleagues
here and I promise you it will never
happen again thank
you all right so
it's it's it is it is not against the
rules you are if you introduce a bill
you are not allowed to ask questions and
apparently it is a custom that in the uh
that you are not um if you were in some
leadership position apparently you're
not supposed to you know continue to act
in the leadership position but there's
nothing wrong with you returning to your
seat that that that's we did that okay
I'm I'm GNA have to get that clarified
because uh I really don't want to do
anything I'm not supposed to be thanks I
appreciate that very much all right so
um we're now going to I'm going to open
the hearing on um HB 476 and I will
recognize the prime sponsor
representative ktie pno representative P
good morning thank you chairman Lynn and
members of the committee and members of
the public originally I was coming in to
introduce House Bill
476 however a request for withdrawal has
sub been submitted to the house clerk
thank you all right so ladies and
gentlemen just so that you understand
and um what is what this means there has
been a a uh according to representative
pill she has submitted a request to have
the bill
withdrawn that as I understand the rules
and I you know if somebody if I'm wrong
on this because this is not something
that has happened happens very often if
I'm wrong on this and somebody has uh
knows knows that I'm wrong please
correct me but the process is that when
this kind of a request happens at this
stage where a bill has already been
scheduled for a
hearing all the the sponsor and all of
the co-sponsors have to agree and then
the matter has to go to the house floor
for a vote of the house floor whether to
approve the withdrawal of the bill that
could not happen at the earliest until
February 6th so the bottom line of that
and who knows whether that would happen
or not so the bottom line is we are
going going forward with the hearing
today on the bill and the amendment so
I'm going to um uh you know obviously
the the fact that the sponsor and
apparently co-sponsors have requested to
withdraw the bill I would think I could
be wrong on this but I would think that
strongly increases the chance that the
bill will not succeed but I don't know
that um for sure so we're going to have
your you know so obviously people who
have who have heed here to testify where
we're going to have the hearing and you
and uh you know we'll proceed with the
hearing so I'm going to uh next call uh
Nancy Pariser and I'm gonna because I
have this is the stack of cards I have
uh so we're gonna I'm G to ask everyone
to please confine your remarks to three
minutes okay um thank you Nancy Pariser
please
morning Miss par you press the button on
that so when the red light come so the
red light comes on there you go thank
you thank you thank you New Hampshire
should be proud proud of the fact that
we have a low maternal mortality rate
and the lowest teen pregnancy rate in
America this is not by chance this is
due to the hard work that the medical
community provides for the women of New
Hampshire since 2022 since Row versus
Wade was overturned the states with laws
like HB 476 have the highest maternal
mortality rate and teen pregnancy rate
the more restrictive the higher the rate
this is not by chance it is true of all
states that have adopted restrictions
like HB
476 America has the highest maternal
mortality rate in the industrialized
world this is an American crisis and
work needs to be done to reverse this
deplorable statistic and not contribute
to it by adopting laws like HB
476 the consequences of HB 476 are
Beyond abortion access it will affect
all women of reproductive age and Beyond
restrictive laws result in Obi deserts
which is the term used for a severe
shortage of OBGYNs we train OBGYN
residents from Dartmouth and TS
University here in New Hampshire all
residents must complete a residency pro
project recently I asked a resident what
she was focused on for her project and
she replied Obie deserts she is from
Utah and her preliminary investigation
indicated that 80% of OBGYNs had left
her home state since
2022 does New Hampshire want to become
an OB desert the residents will not be
adequately trained to handle a
complicated medical condition arising
from a restrictive law like HB 476 nor
will they choose to practice here we
need young well-trained Obi Joan
providers to stay in practice ice in New
Hampshire not drive them away with
restrictive laws a few years ago an obgy
colleague of mine in Houston Texas was
informed that a 17-year-old woman had
died of sepsis in her hospital that
morning in Houston Texas a world leader
of medical care this young woman was
pregnant and suffered the unfortunate
circumstance of breaking her water at 18
weeks too early for fetal viability and
with the ominous risk of becoming
dangerously infected with sepsis with no
chance for fetal survival she went with
her mother to hospital number one and
because she did not have a fever and a
fetal heartbeat she was told to go home
later that week she went to hospital
number two with the same no fever with a
fetal heart rate go home the next week
she went to hospital number three with a
fever and a fetal heart rate providers
are strapped with an exclusion clause
which I will quote an OB from Dallas
stating it's like a vigilante on your
back with the real chance of
imprisonment for up to 99 years in Texas
so they admitted her and gave her
antibiotics but did not perform the
life-saving procedure you know I'm sorry
you're at your 3 minute limit so I
really appreciate it if you if you if
you had if you want to make one more you
know to wrap up that's fine but just
please do I just want to say that that
woman died and she never sought an
abortion if she lived in New Hampshire
she would be alive today thank you very
much next I'm going to call on Cynthia
rasmusen
please oh and and yes and then you know
what just so that U everybody knows a a
the next witness after M rasm will be uh
Dr
Young I
can thank you oh I
know this one does
yes good was a good
question chairman and members of the
Judiciary Committee my name is Dr
Cynthia rasmason and I'm a New Hampshire
resident I'm a retired obstetrician
gynecologist and I practiced in this
area for 32 years I'm here to testify
against HP 476 which seeks to introduce
a 15we abortion ban one year ago in
January of 2024 I had the privilege of
testifying before the Senate Judiciary
Committee in support of three bills
which would have enshrined the right to
the full spectrum of reproductive care
in the New Hampshire Constitution create
shield laws to protect our medical
providers
uh from out ofate prosecution if we
treat patients who come to New Hampshire
for care and to ensure that citizens
have safe and and effective have access
to safe and effective abortion
medications the committee chose not to
pass any of those bills and the reason
given at the time was because New
Hampshire already had an abortion ban at
24 weeks a compromise that the
legislators on the committee said they
were very pleased with and saw no reason
to change one year later this body is
now proposing a 15we abortion ban
something that our newly elected
Governor repeatedly guaranteed that she
would veto why New Hampshire needs a
more restrictive abortion policy is not
clear to me but what will happen should
this law be passed is on Full display in
other states with abortion bans first
and foremost women will die
unnecessarily since the dobs decision at
least three women have died in Texas due
to delayed or mismanaged second
trimester miscarriage care dying from
Advanced infection or fatal Hemorrhage
while local laws forbade or delayed
appropriate And Timely Care at least two
women have died in Georgia both from
infection caused by incomplete emptying
of the uterus State Medical re review
boards in both States ruled that those
deaths were preventable but in Georgia
the performance of a DNC the surgical
procedure used to empty the uterus can
be a felony and in Texas Medical
providers who who violate the state's
abortion ban risk up to 99 years in
prison fines of of $100,000 and loss of
their medical licenses exceptions to
protect the life of the mother have not
provided the protections for which they
were intended the confusion over what
medical complications make a pregnancy
too dangerous to continue how sick is
sick enough to intervene how much blood
loss is too much how bad must an
infection get before life-saving
measures can be instituted this
confusion is what creates the delays
that kill women and trying to create
laws which are more explicit about these
issues is Not Practical expecting laws
to account for all the ways that a
pregnancy can go wrong is like expecting
an elephant to play the piano they
really can't do it and the music or in
this case women's lives will suffer the
current New Hampshire ban at 24 weeks
allows that most Mis miscarriage
management can be conducted under the
standard of Safe And Timely Medical Care
decreasing that ban to 15 weeks does not
in fact reduce the number of abortions
performed and pushes the most complex
miscarriage management into the gray
areas which are so fatal for women and
be aware that this 15we ban includes no
exceptions for rape incest or the health
of the mother desperate women will take
matters into their own hand I'm sorry
you're you're 3 minutes is up um
terrific so if you if you have a you
know one or two more sentences you want
to finish up that's fine but I we have a
lot of people here today I I do um that
uh the previous speaker spoke about um
about OBG Wan's leaving the area and and
Care deserts that way it isn't just
OBGYN um uh other Specialties that uh
that have people leave the area because
of abortion banss include emergency
medicine Family Medicine okay so yeah
I'm sorry I was saying like
had one couple of sentences fine but not
okay and and obviously if you have
written say this to anybody if you have
written testimony please we're gonna
we're going to consider that thank you
very much next I'm going to call on Dr o
young and on Deck will be uh Bonnie
Bruno Dr Young welcome thank you and
thank you all for your your service
service um for those of you who don't
know me uh I'm Dr o young uh practiced
Obi Joan conquered for almost 40 years
I'm a past president of the New
Hampshire Medical
Society I've served on our general
Council representing all of the OBG in
the state of New Hampshire for 20
years I also taught Dartmouth medical
students during those 40 years of
practice they would come down for their
third year clerkship
in
OBGYN years ago I was a thirdy year
medical student doing my OB Joan
clerkship at St Paul Ramsey County
Hospital in St Paul Minnesota when we
admitted a young woman with fever
shaking chills vaginal bleeding and
severe
hypotension in septic Chuck she
confessed that she had had an illegal
abortion the week before we gave her IV
fluids and the best antibiotics we had
at the time and we took her to the
operating room and removed her infected
perforated uterus and washed pus from
her
pelvis our patient had a septic abortion
which was not uncommon in those days
prior to row v
Wade this young woman was an honor
student she was Captain of her
basketball team team in high
school I asked her if she'd informed her
parents of her pregnancy she confided in
me that her father was responsible for
the
pregnancy and she would die before she
told her mom she was
pregnant unfortunately a few days later
she did
die during my 5 years of training as an
intern and OBG residency and almost 40
years of practice I did not see to my
knowledge another woman with a
septic
abortion fortunately I was blessed
during my time of practice as an obser
gynecologist Row the roow decision had
been made making certain that women had
access to Safe
abortion I was trained to perform the
procedure that terminated the pregnancy
and I did provide that for my patients
who made that difficult decision I fear
that we could return to the brutal
deaths of young women suffering sepsis
after illegal abortions because of the
reversal of roie
Wade after almost 50 years of
Compassionate
Care you folks lawmakers who know
nothing your of a woman's
life i' ask you should ever have a voice
in Her care when it comes to
pregnancy abortion is not about politics
doctor I'm sorry one sence providing
private safe Health Care to women gives
them control over their bodies and the
freedom to make this world a better
place thank you thank you Doctor all
right next I'm going to
call all right no no no come on come on
let's stop next Bonnie Bruno and the
next person up will be Michael
Lewis hi thanks for having this public
hearing this 18-year-old was crying in
pain too weak to walk blood staining her
thighs feverish vomiting the day of her
baby shower she died After experiencing
pregnancy complications because of
abortion
restrictions this 26-year-old Who Loved
camping hiking and was an avid Harry
Potter fan as I
am she died after not being able to get
access to an abortion for an eptic
pregnancy she left behind a husband and
a small son a young son both of these
women are dead because of abortion bans
and restrictions please vote no to
oppose HB
476 thank you very much um next uh
Michael Lewis please and
um uh the next witness after that will
be uh
Lorna kuso I think carile sorry all
right
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee fellow graned Staters uh I'm
on the other side of the issue of the
pro- life but I see no enemies here I
see people trying to do the right thing
and just uh we don't agree on what the
right thing is I've uh given you the
written
testimony so uh I think I think I like
the bill I like the direction the bill
moving in uh I thought it maybe needed
some more support maybe we need to
collect signatures CU people just you
know vot on 24 weeks or take some other
steps I list some suggestions there for
you uh but I also like that the bill
positioned us to aim higher and save
even more lives so uh if you if you
think you can get it past just the way
it is fantastic go for it but if not
there's some suggestions for improvement
in here uh including uh attacking that
mat interal mortality rate kind of look
at a whole ecosystem of lives get
focused on saving lives and I I hear my
colleagues with lives lost uh we got to
do everything we can to save lives next
picture kind of shows what 15 weeks does
for us in Saving Lives it's uh every
block is 1% in here so today we allowed
about 99% of abortions this would take
it down to about 95 so it's a modest
Improvement but in not Improvement
nevertheless to save some lives but we
could be uh crushing that and uh really
save given many many more lives by kind
of stepping away from the practice but
retaining all the things that saved the
lives of the mother there is another
life that's lost every time there's an
abortion and uh that a picture it's a
little hard to see was another rookie
mistake I uh I intended to give each of
you a little model but I heard you don't
accept props so I'll just put this back
in my pocket but that's uh that's a 10we
old not a 15we oldal 2 in long got her
own DNA got her own face fingers uh toes
and more I just don't think that wiping
nose out is Healthcare right I think we
can do better uh you know we're all
created at one point equal with the
right to life liberty Pursuit of
Happiness what was that moment of
creation we all had the same start we
all started as that embryo you me
everybody that was everyone that ever
will be that's a human that's that's all
a person is at that point in time I
think it all depends how you frame the
issue is it a three-person reality with
a man and a woman and another life
involved or is it a oneperson reality
just a woman's issue I think it's a
three-person reality and in conclusion
I'd say there are many other realities
we've embraced in our history we used to
think slavery was acceptable killing
Native Americans right smoking was not
harmful right and how about those oxy
painkillers we have destroyed millions
and millions of lives with these things
that we've clinged to and for me
abortion is on this list more millions
of lives destroyed if you consider the
person inside you know a human life and
so it kind comes down to that you know
are we going to you know have this on
our list of big regrets or we going to
step away from it I promise you this sir
your your three minute time is really up
so I'd appreciate if you if you have one
or two more sentences fine but then I'd
like to ask you to uh yeah finish up
that's a prediction making it on that
list here's a promise we will never
regret focusing on saving lives thank
you for your time you very much all
right Miss Carlile and the next uh
witness will be repres after M carile
will be representative Jee n um Mr chair
yeah could you please make clear to the
audience that we do not um tolerate or
accept uh expressions of approval or
disapproval we just listen respectfully
to what people say that's your
representative Smith is absolutely right
please uh you know refrain from the we
the theatrics it it's not uh it's it's
not particularly helpful and I I suspect
P persuasive to anyone anyway please go
ahead hi so first thing I'll say right
off the bat my mother had nine kids
three more pregnancies a still born and
two miscarriages she'd probably be a
criminal today and I just think this is
appalling um in the newspaper was
suggested that women should just give
their babies up for adoption that's fine
for a man to say but many women
experience debilitating morning sickness
for months if she has to miss work
because she's sick who is replacing that
income many service sector jobs don't
even offer paid sick time many employers
discriminate against women for the very
fact that they can get pregnant I worked
at a company that paid for college
classes except they were reluctant to do
so because I could get pregnant and
leave justess how many men improved
their education only to move on to a
better paying job I know I could not
give up a child for adoption worrying
about where that child is and was it
being treated lovingly as a single
parent I had to miss workk anytime my
child was sick many two parent
households this still falls on the woman
the average cost of daycare if you can
even find it is approximately $77,000 a
year
$325 a week you can forget about working
if if you have two kids housing in the
state of New Hampshire is beyond the
reach of many people basic necessities
like groceries heating bills electricity
Etc are stressing family budgets you're
accusing women of being frivolous for
considering financial reasons not to
have a child it seems irresponsible to
have a child or children when you can't
afford it you talk about the state
giving support to the child until it
reaches 18 nice try but the state and
Hampshire can't pay their own bills
especially the cost of Education a woman
needs financial help through Medicaid or
welfare lawmakers want to force her off
to to get off to work or off the program
all together so no I don't believe you
will help for a second politicians have
no business deciding when or if a family
brings a child into this world I suggest
you work on high property taxes the lack
of affordable housing and child care
which would help more families actually
be able to afford having a child and I
could add that a woman's overall
lifetime income is generally lower if
she has to stay home and take care of
children she misses out on promotions at
work her social security benefits of
401k contributions will suffer thank you
thank you uh representative genan ner
please and next will be uh Lynn Hill
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
members of the committee I'll I'll be
very quick um there was an email sent
out this morning telling the pro-life
Community to stay home because they'd
heard that the will the bill had been
withdrawn um I did not get that email it
was shown to me down the hall um and I
know that this bill isn't likely to pass
and both parties are against it but for
different reasons and I certainly don't
want to jeopardize the small gains we
have made in the in the Life issue
I understand why an amendment was
drafted and I co-sponsor the same uh the
statistics bill in the other body but
with all due respect to my caucus I have
a higher power to answer to and my
conscience dictates that I must go on
record supporting the sanctity of
innocent human life lastly to quote Dr
Seuss a person is a person no matter how
small thank you thank you um uh next
would be Lynn Hill and on Deck will be
Paul uh
gaso good morning hi I tell my children
there are no good outcomes to an
unwanted pregnancy not a Loveless
marriage not abortion and not adoption
all of these possibilities are flawed
New Hampshire abortion laws are already
adequate no one can get an abortion in
the third trimester except for the life
of the mother or fatal fetal diagnosis
10 to 20% of pregnancies end in
miscarriage that's uh data from Mayo
Clinic this bill could force a girl to
seek an abortion for a pregnancy that
might have ended
naturally according to the CDC only a
very small percentage of abortions occur
in the in the third trimester about 1%
and you cannot find someone to do this
just because you want an abortion right
you got to have a real reason for that
so most um 90 to 95 % of abortions occur
in the first trimester about five to six
in the
second um this date is corroborated by
Willie Parker a man of strong faith who
changed his Outlook that helping women
in need is like being a Good Samaritan
his book is called life's work and I
strongly recommend it he went from being
a fundamentalist Christian to being a
compassionate Christian providing
abortion in Alabama 15 weeks is just not
enough time to realize your PR schedule
the doctor's appointment schedule an
appointment with an abortion provider
travel to the appointment and incur the
cost this also assumes the girl not only
tracks her periods but has regular
periods and this is not often the case
and one have any of us tried to get a
medical or specialty appointment
recently my doctors are often scheduling
three months out or further and there
are fewer abortion providers available
every day thanks to pressure from
legislators and so-called religious
groups trans transportation and cost are
a huge barrier to the
girl I think legislators who pass
abortion restrictions often picture
these unwanted pregnancies turning into
Happy nuclear families or that the baby
is put up for adoption Studies have
shown that about 10% of women denied an
abortion will actually put the baby up
for adoption there are many reasons for
this and of course where are the men
right big it off like scotf
free if a woman keeps a baby she does
not want and did not choose to birth it
may end okay but you should consider the
more likely Alternatives children
unwanted
neglected abused living in squal or in
filthy Apartments living with parents on
drugs with no food in the house 133% of
New Hampshire children are food
insecure I work at a food bank uh the
children may also even be homeless I
would recommend a book called
evicted children in uced into a home
where there already too little money
time and food is not
optimal these are homes where food and
electricity your time is up I'd ask you
to please finish up I will um there are
many reasons um that I oppose this bill
I would implore you uh to vote against
it if it comes to being let women decide
about their bodies and their lives thank
you very much right Paul gasso and next
up will be James John uh
Johnston hi good morning my name is Paul
galasso gaso version I hadn't heard in a
while um I'm here to support the bill uh
quick background I do sidewalk advocacy
for life been doing this for a Dozen
Years talk to hundreds and hundreds of
women going in and girls I should say
women and girls coming out I want to
talk about what happens to the baby I
know a lot happens to pregnant moms that
don't want to have children but what
happens to the baby I'll try to do this
as brief briefly as possible but um I
want you also to know that uh you can
look this information up
WebMD uh Mayo Clinic uh Dartmouth
Hitchcock okay there's four types uh
medical abortion uh the are you 46 two
Bill procedure first bill deprives the
baby of needed protein the baby dies and
then the second Bill causes miscarriage
uh these little babies uh are then um
miscarried in toilets and Flushed Away
first trimester
surgical is an evacuation process uh
vacuum basically is used to remove uh
the the baby uh uh relatively less
complicated second trimester is a
dilation and evacuation where there's
forp used uh to remove the baby and then
a cur it to scrape the inside to make
sure there isn't any residual uh baby
body uh material in the
uterus and then in the third trimester
it's uh dilation and
extraction and in this case the baby of
course is welldeveloped uh ready to be
born and uh forceps are used in this
case but they have grips on the ends
because they remove the baby's
limbs uh if removing the baby's limbs is
not adequate to remove the baby from the
mother's uterus uh the same device is
used to crush the
skull and if that's not adequate they'll
go back to the vacuum device and vacuum
out the baby's brains
this is what we're
allowing to happen in our country
thankfully in the state we've limited
abortions to 24
[Music]
weeks I'd ask you all please just think
about what's really going on here thank
you thank thank you very much sir uh
next is James Johnston and on Deck will
be Erica
Russell thank you chairman Lynn and uh
committee members um my name is James
Johnston and I am here against this bill
um and I'm not going to talk about
anything about you know what happens to
the women's body because there's so many
more stories here than what I can
provide but there's two main points that
I wanted to come and talk about the two
points are one is I uh was raised uh
Christian uh raised nazarine and I am uh
a believer in Christ but I also believe
the fact that we have the choice of
religion within the United States and
the government is not um in a position
to be forcing certain viewpoints upon us
uh as Citizens to you know do one thing
or not do one thing based off of a uh a
religious standpoint or a religious
upbringing the second point is the great
thing about New Hampshire and one of the
reasons why I actually live here is the
fact that it is Live Free or Die is our
motto right we're here to you know live
free and be able to make our own choices
and choose the things that you know we
want to do without government in
interference you know where where is the
history of you know small government
right why why should the government be
pushing things on to us you know um and
and the fact is is that you know if you
know me and my partner were to have a
child right now you know it would go
ahead and and financially burden us to a
point that you know it wouldn't it
wouldn't make sense to us right it it
would cause us to potentially be a
burden on the state even further by
having a child because then you know if
I need a good EBT or or or similar and
so the thing
is people get to make their own choice
if it's founded by a choice on on
religion and on the sanc of Life great
they get to choose that but why is the
government why is the the state trying
to tell us what we can or cannot do and
I I I support people's decisions to you
know go ahead and you know you know
respect the the pregnancy and go and and
have that to term but I also respect the
choices of people to not do that and the
government should not be telling us what
to do thank you very much thank you very
much sir
Erica Russell and on Deck will be Dr
David
Crowley
morning members of the House Judiciary
Committee my name is Erica Russell I'm
here to oppose house bill number
476 I'm a nurse practitioner and a nurse
Midwife who has served the community for
over 25 years my core responsibility as
a health care provider is is to offer
comprehensive options and support my
patients in making informed decisions
about their care we're not ask could you
move just a little bit closer to the
microphone maybe thank you thanks sure
um but we are not just talking about any
patient are we we're talking about
people with
uteruses throughout my career I've
encountered women facing incredibly
challenging circumstances survivors of
sexual assault those caring pregnancies
with devast fetal diagnoses women who
become pregnant despite careful
contraceptive use individuals navigating
poverty and family instability we've
seen an increase in maternal morbidity
and we've seen the devastating effects
of drug use on people's lives I've also
witnessed the profound and beautiful
bonds between mothers and children and
their incredible resilience even in
difficult pregnancies and births as a
mother of three daughters and
anticipating the joy of becoming a
grandmother I understand the Prof found
responsibility of Parenthood however if
any of my children were to face an
unintended pregnancy or if medical
complications arose that jeopardized
their health I would unequivocably
support their right to access safe and
legal abortion Care at any point in
their pregnancy like I said I really
really want grandchildren but it's
really not my decision it's not my life
that will be impacted it's not my body
that will carry the pregnancy and it
shouldn't be your decision either in
summary given my commitment to patient
autonomy offering support and
information to make informed choices I
cannot in good conscience support
lawmakers dictating Medical Care
patients in partnership with their
trusted healthc care providers should
really be the ones making the difficult
choice to get an abortion or continue
with their pregnancy at 6 weeks of
pregnancy at 8 weeks of pregnancy at 15
weeks of pregnancy at 24 weeks of
pregnancy thank you thank you very much
much um next is Dr Crowley and then
after Dr Crowley I I I want
to oh I'm sorry do you have written
testimony ma'am you did you have written
testimony to pass out to pass
out yes
yes I
have
I uh so anyway next we're gonna have Dr
Crowley and then after Dr Crowley I um
one of my fellow Representatives pointed
out that right in the I guess in the
front row there it appears that we have
a woman with two children one of whom
seems to have been standing for quite a
while so I'm going to call on you after
we hear from Dr Crowley I'm GNA call on
you next
okay thank
you
Dr good morning I am Dr David Crowley I
live in Bedford New Hampshire I work
full-time for Dartmouth Hitchcock my My
Views are my own and and are informed by
14 years of practice here in the state I
oppose this bill unlike many of the
other medical providers you're going to
hear today I am not in the obstetrician
of any type I do not perform abortions I
do not counsel my patients either for or
against
abortion what I do as I tell my
8-year-old son is I'm a baby heart
doctor my official title is a pediatric
and Fetal cardiologist I'm a
pediatrician who can diagnose and treat
children who have heart disease
all the way down to those still in the
womb I refer those that need surgery to
a pediatric heart surgeon and I think
it'll help this group to understand how
my practice works the standard of
medical care for pregnant women is to
have an ultrasound performed by their OB
at 18 to 20 weeks of pre pregnancy
called an an an anatomy scan if the OB
has any reason to suspect or has already
found a heart problem they refer the
mother to me for a more a second and
more detailed
fetal echo cardiogram and ultrasound of
the heart it is usually performed at 21
to 23 weeks of
gation only 4% of abortions occur 16
weeks and later of those 3% occur 16 to
20 weeks and 1% after 21 weeks so why
does this bill Target them these
4% are my patients this bill unfairly
targets some some of them and will harm
some of them my patients need more than
15 weeks to identify the major fetal
anomalies that influence such impactful
decisions they rarely get this
information before 20 weeks the timing
of both the anatomy scan in the ob's
office and the fetal echocardiogram in
mind are hardcoded into our medical
system they are based on when we can
obtain the best images to get the best
data to get the best information to our
families so they can make these hard
decisions
doing it earlier would result in
incomplete data and missed diagnosis and
it's only after these families have been
given this information that they can
make what we call an informed decision
about their own care this bill will
disrupt that personal and private
decision it will steal their autonomy it
will give it to the state this bill will
remove the informed from the informed
consent process it will insert a party
that has no place to make this type of
medical decision everyone has the right
to make their own informed decisions
about their own Medical Care medical
autonomy is a core principle of medical
ethics once I diagnose a fetus with a
heart job with a heart disease my job is
to give the parents information and
options during a consultation I cover an
enormous range of topics that I don't
have time in three minutes to cover
today
when my patients receive this they may
seek additional counsel from their
spouse or partner from their extended
family their support groups their
spiritual leaders their obstat other I'd
appreciate if you'd finish up okay I
will wrap up all of that takes
time in summary a reduction in the legal
limit from 24 to 15 weeks will harm the
very New Hampshire families who need our
help the most who are confronted with
the hardest medical decision they will
ever making their life I implore you to
vote against this bill give Specialists
like me the opportunity to assess our
patients to inform to educate to give to
discuss these things with the patients
to help them determine for themselves
what is best for their family thank you
very much do right right next um ma'am I
you I think you you are the with the two
young children so please
I come on up just that one
uh good morning thank you that was very
kind of you and thank you um for finding
me SE tell tell us who you are please
okay thank you I'm sorry my name is is
Leah Easley um and I'm here with my
daughter Magdalena and my um niece
Olivia um and I actually was planning on
being here in a purely observational
capacity but um thank you for for um
noticing and actually we probably do
have to head out soon for a nap time for
the little one um but I will say U as a
we are um a a pro-life family um because
we um for many reasons and we we
understand
the the challenges and the Heartbreak of
unintended pregnancies and difficult
circumstances um we have been foster
parents my husband and I um and um we
actually my daughter is is adopted and
um that was the result of a decision her
birth mother made um after um actually
having an abortion the month before she
was conceived um and then when my the
birth her birth mother conceived her um
just felt
very um convicted to hry through with a
pregnancy and it has been a wonderful
relationship with um magdalen's birth
parents and
um obviously my husband and I are very
grateful for her decision um and um we
are there there are you know I know
adoption people have said like it's not
an option for everyone and they still
need to go through that pregnancy which
I know can be very difficult um but
adoption is a very real option there are
so many parents in the United States
today foster parents uh waiting for
adoptive parents who would be delighted
to adopt there are far more adoptive
parents waiting um than there are
children like that are being adopted out
so there there is we do have the
capacity um to receive and give children
homes and I know it's bigger than that
um but I would just like to to put that
down as well um and and thank you um I
like I said I wasn't I was planning on
simply observing but I will say that and
thank you for offering me seating room I
appreciate that and it was much more
comfortable with the two kids um and now
I think I'm going to take this one off
for her her nap time so thank you thank
you very much so next I'm going to
call oh you know what I
excuse me ma'am can I just ask did you
submit a pink card did you fill out a
pink oh you know so can I just ask you
over there there if you just wouldn't
mind filling it out and just passing it
down we'll take care of it so next I'm
going to call on Riley Ward and then
after Riley Ward um I see a couple of
folks uh senior citizens like myself who
are standing in the back of the room and
if you plan to testify I'm going to ask
you to come up after uh Riley Ward okay
hello everyone my name is Riley Ward I
am 17 years old and I lived in Raymond
New Hampshire my whole life I should be
at school today but with my mom's
permission I'm instead sitting here in
front of you because I believe I should
have the right to make decisions about
my own body and because the last time
this governing body passed an abortion
ban they told us 24 weeks is where they
would stop yet here I am
a 17-year-old girl sitting in front of
you asking you not to give up control of
my body but not to tighten your
grip I love this state my family is here
as well as many of my friends I may come
back to New Hampshire after college I
may not I don't know but I do know that
wherever my future takes me I want to be
in a place where I can control my own
body and control my own future my
friends who decide to stay in New
Hampshire and those I love who already
called New Hampshire Home deserve that
as well you all as politicians should
should not be the ones making decisions
about anyone's bodies there will be
always be there will always be things I
cannot control but I know I don't want
to be in a state where I can't control
my own body these decisions that you all
are making will have profound impacts on
my future as well as others Futures and
will have an impact on where I as many
as well as many other young kids will
choose to be in their Futures thank you
thank you very much U uh yes come on up
U and sir I'll ask uh I'll ask I'll call
on you next so you know please come up
and do you want I'm not saying you have
to speak if you want to speak you can
and sir in the back of the room if if
you're interested in speaking okay no
that's fine there it yeah you can
there's a seat if you're interested up
in the front all right next I'm going to
call on uh
fidelma McKenna and the next on Deck
after that will be
Mariam
aini
right sorry hi good morning I'm here to
oppose this bill my name is fidelma I'm
a certified nurse Midwife and I've been
working in reproductive health for 15
years and I have the privilege of
delivering babies at a hospital in New
Hampshire as well as working at a
quality Health Center taking care of
patients getting abortions when I think
about the founding of equality 50 years
ago on Main Street in the city's capital
and when I ask how it came to be people
often describe a very different
political climate where conservative
values were present along with
Progressive ones but legislating
Healthcare decisions was not a priority
for the government of New Hampshire I
know we find ourselves in a very
different political climate now but
we're still in New Hampshire and we as
Citizens still pride ourselves on small
government limited executive overreach
and Live Free or Die I believe in you as
state politicians and that you're here
to represent the values of GR Staters
not to advance a national political
agenda which introducing increasingly
limited destinational limit on abortions
is I believe you're here to fight for
the best possible outcomes for your
community and I know that your job is to
represent your constituents not to
understand all the ins and outs of a
very complicated medical condition
that's why so many of us are here as
midwives nurses and obes and
cardiologists the medical experts to
tell you this bill is wrong for New
Hampshire this bill would ban abortions
at 15 weeks before all the essential
prenatal testing is complete and before
most of the truly difficult and
dangerous complications of pregnancy
develop I have so many examples I wish I
could share with you to explain why this
bill is wrong from a busy single mother
whose hyperemesis gravidarum or
Relentless nausea and vomiting made her
daily existence torture and prevented
her from working to provide for her
three kids as well as playing with them
caring for them making them feel
treasured and loved as they deserved to
so many parents attempting to leave
domestic violence situations and turn
their kids lives around or a young woman
with a new diagnosis of breast cancer
who has to choose between her welcomed
and desired pregnancy and her cancer
treatment none of these situations are
technically life-threatening but they
are danger Dangerous and health
threatening I could also tell you a
situations of uncertainty and fear where
a patient is bleeding and getting sicker
with a miscarriage but because the
pregnancy still has a heartbeat we risk
delays in Essential Medical Care because
the healthcare team is uncertain in this
political climate what's allowed
emergent Medical Care being delayed
because we have allowed the government
to start dictating the decisions that
should be made by medical experts and
their patients also New Hampshire is a
proudly rural State and I see many
patients traveling for over an hour or 2
hours to get their abortion care and a
15-week ban disproportionately affects
our rural communities who struggle
already with access to timely Healthcare
including a pregnancy diagnosis and I
know you are all here to fight for the
well-being of our citizens rural or
Urban and not to legislate barriers
against them now we live this every day
as medical experts in reproductive care
so it's our job to tell you that every
pregnancy is so different so in the best
interest of granite Staters we cannot
legislate Medical Care stand up and
defend New Hampshire's small government
values Live Free or Die and leave these
excruciating and difficult decisions to
the patients and their
providers thank you very much next uh I
I I know I butchered the last name and I
apologize Mariam e e
exom all right and next up will be uh
Laura
elazim
Elam yes sir um my name is Miriam exom
um thank you chairman and members of the
committee um I'm from the south um my
husband and I left Atlanta and moved to
Royal Tennessee in 2015 for our our
dream life on a farm we have two young
daughters um when the heartbeat laws
started passing um you know we we were
watching and we thought about moving
back to Atlanta um or moving to the
Northeast my husband and I he's from
Middle Georgia and his whole family's
there he took a leap because he loves
his daughters and me and he moved to the
Northeast we um we love the taxes in
Tennessee just like we love the taxes in
New Hampshire and we chose the state for
a
reason
um we We Want To Live Free or Die and we
don't want um we don't want our
children to have the restrictions that
are sweeping the ation thank you for
your time thank you very much um Laura
uh elazim and next up will be
Stephanie
har har Haron
Anon AR okay all right yes hi you are
correct thank you it's Laura El aam I
live in London Derry and I'm here in
support of this bill I understand some
of the uh back and forth about why it
may have been withdrawn but in general I
like to see New Hampshire moving in the
direction that this bill is headed and
there's a couple of reasons for that um
I heard someone say that we shouldn't be
pushing religious views on everybody
with uh laws like this and I just want
to point out that the fact that this
that we're talking about a h an human
individual in the womb isn't a religious
um opinion it it's just scientific and
biological fact from conception it's a
human entity it's um it's a developing
child it's not a clumb of cells um it is
a developing child and this is just
scientific fact a couple of weeks ago I
had the opportunity to see my niece who
was eight weeks pregnant at the time and
she actually had an ultrasound video of
the twins that she's currently carrying
they're not Blobs of cells they're her
going to be her children they are
already her children and in this amazing
video you can see these two separate
entities with their little hearts
beating even at just 8 weeks
um and I think it would be important for
the for the Live Free or Die State since
it's been brought up a couple of times
to recognize the humanity and to work
towards
having a a cultural mindset that tries
to get us to save both lives there are a
lot of people who've distinguished
themselves with white coats and medical
equipment in this room who are telling
us about all the difficulties and
uncertainties they face when they're
trying to treat their patients um
I I think that once we begin to treat
both patients as actual human
individuals worthy of life then those
decisions will become easier because
they'll be able to affirmatively attempt
to save both lives in every instance and
um the more we can work towards that the
more Justice Society we will have the
Freer we'll be all be able to be and
just one final quick Point um I'm the
mother of four adopted children I know a
lot of adults who were adopted as
children and that's not a bad outcome um
the parents of these children that were
adopted get to know that their their
children are growing up usually safe and
in a much better situation than dead um
right now there's about 2 million people
in the United in the United States
seeking children to adopt and there are
about
120,000 children eligible to um for
adoption people go all over the world to
try to adopt children because it's a
good healthy life affirming choice and
um i' would like to see us just
recognize that imbalance here that there
are a lot of parents who would would
give loving homes to to the babies that
are currently being aborted thank you
very much thank you uh
Stephanie Arnon Hannon I'm sorry I just
can't AR okay Arlo And next up will be
Erica
Ivers yes please yeah we'll yeah just
we'll pass him around thank
you good morning morning members of the
committee thank you so much for having
me I'll read my written testimony and of
what going off script as much as
possible um my name is Dr Stephanie
harlo I am a board certified
pediatrician and a practicing OBGYN
resident physician at Dartmouth
Hitchcock in Lebanon I'm here speaking
on behalf of myself
today there are many aspects of this
bill that I believe would cause
gratuitous harm and suffering to New
Hampshire
families and I want to share a story
from actually when I was a Pediatrics
resident to exemplify that I remember
child I I cared for in my ped's
residency that was born with multiple
congenital anomalies a single fused eye
a fused nose and mouth failing kidneys
and a liver so hard that it was
described as plastic he had tubes in
nearly every orifice of his body down
into his Airway into his esophagus
multiple out of his abdomen Ivy lines in
his
arms every day that I rounded on him I
worried he was suffering
after living for a year in the hospital
like this he
died his family was unable to keep
visiting him during much of that year
both because of their eventual need to
return to work and their need to care
for other
children one of my greatest fears with
this proposed bill is that we will be
forcing New Hampshire families into this
kind of
suffering the majority of fetal
anomalies are not diagnosed until 18 to
weeks with confirmation of complex
diagnoses often not being made until
even after
that while the bill describes exceptions
for fetal anomalies incompatible with
life this narrow definition would
exclude many anomalies which are
profoundly life-limiting and attribute a
tremendous amount of
suffering no law can account for the
Nuance of every
situation questions about complex
pregnancy outcomes should only be
addressed by an expert
clinician who understands the
implications of a diagnosis and can
guide a family through challenging
questions to a decision that reflects
their values and minimizes
suffering additionally as has been
alluded to before this bill would harm
patients and families in New Hampshire
by making the state of New Hampshire
inhospitable to obstetric
Providers I am planning to continue my
training in Maternal Fetal Medicine
meaning I would care for highrisk
pregnancies I would be
diagnosing these severe anomalies and
having to turn patients
away that's against my code of ethics as
a
clinician I also think waiting until
someone is near a life-threatening or
severe bodily harm injury is also
against my code of ethics as a physician
ma'am could I just ask you to wrap up
you're at the three point sure thank you
so much I won't go off script anymore um
just abortion is a a compassionate
procedure for people who are facing
unimaginable circumstances so thank you
for listening thank you very much next
is uh Erica Evers and on Deck will be uh
Kyrie
ciac good morning and thank you all for
letting me speak today my name is Dr
Erica iers and I'm an Obstetrics and
Gynecology resident physician I here
today to express my strong opposition to
HB
476 there are many issues with this
legislation that my colleagues have
covered so eloquently but I want to
specifically bring to your attention the
problem that exists with the exemption
for medical
emergency let me give you an example of
how impossible it is to Def excuse me to
define life-saving or medical
emergency a patient who is 17 weeks
pregnant presents to an emergency room
with a fever after breaking her water
this is known as pre-term premature
rupture of membranes and is something
that we see many times each year the
protective barrier between the outside
world and the inside of her uterus has
disappeared allowing bacteria to grow in
this moment she is stable but what
happens next is unpredictable it could
be a matter of hours or days before the
infection spreads throughout the whole
body but a life-threatening infection in
this scenario is absolutely preventable
before it progresses too far and becomes
fatal do I wait until her heart starts
racing the first signs her body is
trying to compensate for spreading
infection do you think a hospital lawyer
would feel I am legally protected to do
my job once her blood pressure starts to
drop and she becomes
confused in no other context would a
doctor be waiting with the patient until
she needed to be sent to the ICU on life
support before they were allowed to do a
proced procedure that she needed to save
her life as a physician it is against my
code of ethics to delay care knowing the
risks to my patient when such
complications become severe enough to be
life-threatening permanent harm is often
already
done these are the questions doctors and
states with medical emergency exceptions
are asking
themselves none of this ambiguity has
been clarified by the courts and there's
little to no legal precedent that exists
doctors in these states are afraid to
treat their
patients in the hours it can take for an
otherwise healthy patient to become
unstable you want your doctor focused on
working alongside you in diagnosing and
treating your illness not contacting
Hospital lawyers and worried they may
face jail time thank you thank you very
much uh K Kyrie ciac and next will be
Anna Hill please
very polish name my name is Kylie sislak
sislak I'm sorry please I'm going to
start off by saying that I am one of the
people I'm not sitting here in a white
coat um but I'm not a public speaker I'm
not a any way policy I'm a nurse
um I'm a critical care nurse here in New
Hampshire I've recently just accepted a
position at a level one H uh hospital
here um I'm here to testify and oppose
against House Bill 476 and share the
harsh realities that healthcare workers
face when access to Safe legal abortion
is
denied I'd like to paint a picture of a
case that we're seeing all too commonly
now a 28-year-old woman arriving to the
ER she's in severe abdominal pain she's
pale febrile hypotensive and
tartic desperate after escaping an
abusive relationship she attempted an at
home abortion at 15 weeks using
unregulated methods because surgical
abortion was no longer an option in her
State she's bleeding heavily she has
signs of infection she's requiring blood
transfusions tests reveal uterine
perforation retained pregnancy tissue
and
peritonitis despite ICU care she rapidly
declines into septic shock in organ
failure by the next day she developed
DIC
and we exhaust all treatment options
with no family to notify holding her
hand the healthcare workers that care
for her have become her
family this is not just a fictional
story this is the tragic reality when
women are denied access to Safe legal
abortion care this death and so many
others that have already happened could
have been prevented with proper safe
Medical Care and support and while I
deeply respect and support anyone's
religious and philosophical
beliefs this bill is a legislative
matter that should rely on scientific
and medical evidence particularly
regarding what constitutes suffering and
quality of life medical decisions about
whether to continue a pregnancy in these
circumstances are deeply personal and
should be made by the patient in
consultation with their healthcare
provider and respectfully not by
lawmakers I strongly urge you to
consider the real human consequences of
restricting access to reproductive
Healthcare all throughout our country
women are dying when they do not have to
the United States has one of the highest
maternal mortality rates in a developed
country black women being 2.6 times
higher than white our foster care system
is failing I'd like to recognize my
brother who's standing here today he's
the one that looks just like me wearing
the chicken on his
shirt he's here supporting the woman in
his life his sister his fiance his
daughter I recently just became a proud
aunt
after him and my sister-in-law adopted
two beautiful children last year and
while their love and dedication to their
children are remarkable ma'am you're at
your three minute limit I would
appreciate if you could finish up
yep lastly I'm standing here as a woman
that exercised her right to choose in
20121 that was a deeply personal
situation that I chose and it wouldn't
have led me to go on to serving my
community today I'm a first generation
college graduate and not with that
decision I wouldn't have been able to do
what I'm doing today thank you very much
next uh Anna Hill and uh on
Deck will be uh man Maris
tler you have written testimony oh yes I
can hand it to you afterwards only one
copy fine that's fine
y good morning to the committee and
present members of my home state you can
call me Miss Hill I'm here to humbly
oppose House Bill
476 there's been a recent Trend in
conservative politics that I advise
everyone to avoid you should not want to
be on the side of the developing Federal
Administration it's clung to power
through rage and violence and when it
goes out it will go the same way at such
a volatile point in American politics we
need protection real protection bills
like 476 charade as child care but
they're truly a sadistic and perverse
abuse of political power they are not
protection but domination and I
object restricting abortion does not
make happy nuclear families and a
flourishing population it breeds
opportunities for financial stress
Foster abuse and crime forcing someone
to bear and birth a child after an
arbitrary deadline is nothing less than
ruthless and vindictive many people who
seek out an abortion do not have the
time and resources that you expect some
are abuse and incest victims with
limited information and freedom some are
bipolar or of mental conditions that
affect the safety of pregnancy but those
are not addressed in this bill some are
already parents of multiple children
without the time or money for a third or
fourth some are teenage students busy
and scared and without a driver's
license you're assuming everyone can
find out their pregnant usually weeks
after fertilization suddenly decide if
they can raise a new human being through
adulthood and schedule pay for and
receive an abortion at a providing
clinic but these are Under Fire all
before the 15we gestational mark That's
not reasonable for everyone maybe it is
for you but I think people tend to
forget that you are not
everyone your lives may be more
predictable with backup plans and a
guest room with saving account and a
401k this isn't true for every
American to me actual protection is
sacrificing something to keep other
people from harm what they recognize as
harm what has actually hurt them in the
past you do this so they have freedoms
and rights a fulfilling life and agency
where they can choose what they think is
best for them even if you don't like
that choice that's real protection and
we need it now now more than ever you
trusted us to elect our officials why
not trust us with our own lives our own
families and leave a reasonable time
frame to do so that's the end of my
testimony thank you for your time thank
you uh Maris tand and on Deck will be
Courtney
nil oh I'm sorry can we get your uh
written testimon if you just give it
down there that'd be great thank you
thank you
good morning morning my name is Dr Maris
Tolland um I'm an obstetrician
gynecologist I passed out a couple of
copies of written testimony and I also
emailed
it one thing I've heard today is that we
will never regret focusing on saving
lives I agree with that there are a lot
of people in this room who work in
Healthcare who have dedicated their
lives to the profession of learning how
best to save lives and I would implore
the committee to listen to
them we are trying to do the right thing
and if indeed as a society our goal is
to save
lives I would pay attention to how many
people are here talking about their
experiences working in the actual Health
Care System the Health Care system as
probably we all know is is fairly broken
it's increasingly complex there are so
many factors that interfere with
Healthcare provider's ability to deliver
the best the most compassionate and
evidence-based care unnecessary
legislation should never be in another
barrier between the care that we as
Physicians are able to provide to our
patients and their
families every healthc care provider
that works in this room I'm sure can
come up with multi multiple recent or
past examples of patients who they have
personally cared for whose individual
stories um and individual scenarios
would have caused them to suffer greatly
because of a bill like
this senate committee members in States
like Idaho like Texas who have passed
abortion banss that are similar to this
have had to learn the hard way that
these bills cause doctors to leave the
state these bills cause rural delivery
labor and delivery units to close down
they cause patients to travel out of
state to receive necessary care these
bills cause patients to sue their state
governments based on their inability to
access that care they cause psychologic
harm and they can cause
death all of the Physicians and healthc
care providers here today are taking
time away from our patients we're
cancelling our clinics we are coming to
the state house after overnight shifts
we are speaking up from retirement
because we collectively recognize the
imminent disaster that this bill
represents for families of New Hampshire
and for the medical landscape at
large please vote against this Bill
thank you very much ma'am uh Courtney
nil and on Deck will be uh Charlotte
Hastings hey I'm Dr Courtney nil I'm a
practicing OBG on here in conquer
abortion care is an entirely necessary
aspect of healthcare the circumstances
surrounding abortions are vast and there
should should not be judicial claim over
an individual's Healthcare choices no
matter those
circumstances being pregnant is more
dangerous than not being pregnant or of
having an abortion a woman should not be
required to take on this deadly risk if
it's not desired additionally I'm
exceptionally concerned about the
verbiage in this bill which references
criminal action against healthcare
providers who manage abortion care the
line between abortion and management of
spontaneous miscarriage between women
when a woman's life is endangered or not
is truly momentary and ambiguous
there are not always moments of saving
both lives these moments can be the
difference in life or death for a
patient and laws like this are set to
elicit fear amongst doctors and thus
delay care due to worries about
retribution which can destroy one's long
worked for career a career built around
helping others and protecting the health
of women to put this in the context of
your work as a lawmaker instead of mine
as a doctor consider if you were to be
asked to come to a decision on a bill in
a matter of minutes without any
colleagues to debate it with without any
constituents to weigh in your choice
alone and let's make it 4:00 a.m. hour
22 of your shift cuz that's what our
world is like by supporting the bill a
woman and the fetus as it's
parasitically connected to the woman's
life will die and by opposing you may
undergo a lengthy criminal investigation
and risk Financial personal and
professional ruin even if ultimately
it's found that you did act
appropriately this is the decision
you're asking us to make regularly if
this bill were to become a law and one I
suspect none of you would be interested
in making were those really the stakes
on behalf of patients and providers
alike please oppose this Bill thank you
thank you very much uh Charlotte
Hastings and on Deck will be Kristen
banister hi hello um members of the
House Judiciary Committee uh my name is
Dr Charlotte Hastings and when I'm not
on crutches I'm a practicing OBGYN in
New Hampshire I sit before for you today
in strong opposition to HB
476 prior to working in New Hampshire I
briefly trained as an obn in Dallas
Texas at one of the busiest hospitals in
the country we were not able to offer
abortions except in the case of lethal
anomalies or significant risk to the
life of the mother I can assure you
those limitations did not protect the
fetus or the mother they instead limited
the reproductive choices of
well-informed women and muddied the
waters in terms of the safe
evidence-based care that we as
Physicians were able to provide I cared
for 11 and 12 year-olds who were forced
to carry a pregnancy to term not
surprising many many of those fifth and
sixth graders didn't know they were
pregnant until after 15 weeks I was
forced to watch as women came to the
emergency department with pain and
bleeding secondary to ectopic
pregnancies implanted in their C-section
scars these women were at risk of their
uteruses rupturing and potentially dying
but didn't yet meet the level of
significant risk to the life of the
mother and therefore no intervention was
allowed and we had to turn them away
instead of providing the potentially
life-saving care that existed in other
states one patient of mine broke her
water at 19 weeks and instead of being
offered an abortion given that her fetus
was non-viable an option she requested
she was forced to undergo a delivery
following her delivery she had excessive
bleeding and as she was wheeled back to
the o I watched as her husband held a
gasping dying neonate not capable of
living outside the uterus my patient
ultimately required an emergent
hysterctomy and was never able to carry
another baby she was 19 years old I can
only imagine the trauma that she and her
husband live with after that experience
these laws have real consequences I left
Texas because I felt I wasn't training
in a location where I could provide the
safe evidence-based care that I knew
existed and as a result was limiting my
abilities and the safety of my patients
I came to New Hampshire because I knew
I'd be able to provide that care this
bill brings me back to my days in Texas
I hope you will oppose House Bill 476
and allow us to provide the care that
the women of New Hampshire need and
deserve thank you thank you uh next
Kristen banister and on Deck will be
Lori k
hi my name's Dr Kristen banister and
I've been a practicing OBGYN in New
Hampshire for 24
years um as you consider House Bill 476
I think it's important that you all
understand kind of what happens in the
first 20 weeks of pregnancy the first
visit around 8 weeks consists of
ordering lab work discussing future
tests and visits but no ultrasound at 12
weeks we do the first alter sound and
offer blood test to screen for
chromosomal problems the results usually
take about 2 weeks to come back so now
we're at around 14 weeks if the test is
positive for a chromosomal problem the
patient will be referred to a specialist
to discuss further testing assuming
there are no unexpected results from the
early testing the next major visit is at
20 weeks with the anatomic ultrasound
this is the ultrasound that shows us how
the fetus has developed are there any
major malformations or concerning
findings all of the testing that we do
in pregnancy takes time and it is not
until 20 to 22 weeks at the earliest
that we have the information need to say
that a pregnancy is healthy or not I
hope you can understand why 15 weeks is
too early for an abortion restriction
currently New Hampshire allows abortion
hair up until 24 weeks unless there's a
threat to the mother's life or a fetus
with an anomaly considered incompatible
with life at the time of that vote you
heard concerns from my professional
Community about the ambiguity of these
terms we have seen the consequences and
of the confusing language in the other
states as you've heard from the previous
uh providers women are dying from
abortion bans this is avoidable and 100%
stems from abortion restrictions vague
terminology and the threat of legal
repercussions for providers the other
phenomenon we're seeing in states that
are tightening restrictions is that
OBGYN do not want to practice there
they're relocating and recruitment is
difficult this is not just an a loss of
abortion providers but your obstetric
providers your infertility Specialists
and your gynecologic surgeons in short
restricting abortion care compromises
the overall quality of Women's Health
Care the final issue I want to address
is as you consider house build 476 is
the exception for conditions
incompatible with life where is that
line for example if feet is found to
have spinal muscular atrophy will be
born alive and may live several years
but they will slowly Lo lose muscle tone
becoming unable to move and eventually
no no longer able to breathe is that
considered incompatible with life how
long does a baby need to live to count
an hour a month a year 5 years does
quality of life matter there's no
clearcut to this answer to this
Physicians are trained to manage these
complex difficult problems and can still
struggle with what incompatible with
life means legislators should not be
trying to make it a legal standard my
request is that you vote to allow
patients and their Physicians to work
through the medical issues of pregnancy
without the pressure of a 15we deadline
families need solid information support
they need time to process so they can
make an informed decision that is right
for them please do not erode the quality
of Women's Healthcare in New Hampshire
by unnecessarily your time is up could I
ask you to please uh finish up um we do
not want to increase our maternal death
rates and we don't want to see a
migration of Physicians out of our state
please vote against thank you very much
uh Lori Kyer and on Deck is Daniel
McLoud
my name is Lori KY and I thank you all
for being here and for having me um I'm
here in opposition to House Bill
476 this bill puts unnecessary burden on
New Hampshire residents and seeks to
redefine the terms fetus and late term
abortion so that they are not in line
with the science behind pregnancy I want
to ask did any of the authors of this
bill actually speak to an OBGYN or visit
Google before they wrote this bill when
any group of politicians starts making
false assumptions about the science
behind pregnancy we all know that that
is a way to impose their religious
values on people who have the
constitutional right freedom of
religion not the politicians
religion I know we all know this but
sometimes it needs to be said out loud
what the authors of this bill are also
doing is trying to sprinkle in wording
about fetal personhood that prioritizes
the pregnancy over the Pres pregnant
person I believe people who can get
pregnant would choose to have more
babies if New Hampshire started
prioritizing the pregnant person and the
children and life they already
have New Hampshire residents need bills
that will help us in our daily lives
such as food prices gas prices education
healthc care taxes
taxes um so why are we starting here at
the beginning of this um legislative
session with an abortion
ban it's disgusting it has zero to do
with the
economy I don't
understand
so I want to talk about now the uh
mandatory obstetric
ultrasounds first who will be
responsible for paying for this
procedure that is going to be forced on
women by the
government I didn't see that in the bill
I'm sure you didn't
either second are the gentlemen
responsible for drafting this bill at
least a little bit familiar with what an
obstetric ultrasound is well Google is
free and I will start I will offer the
drafters of this bill the name of an
excellent OBGYN here in New Hampshire or
even in this
room that can help you with that concept
the fact that the authors of this bill
make no exceptions for rape or or incest
is inhumane unconscionable and proves to
me the religiosity origins of the bill
to begin with ladies and gentlemen New
Hampshire is not living in the
handmaid's tail yet and I intend on
being here at the state house every time
one of these ridiculous bills comes
up thank you thank you very much uh
Daniel McLoud the fourth uh followed on
Deck will be
uh J L
Hall thank you everyone um my name is D
McLoud I'm from lonary I'm just here as
a concerned citizen husband and father
um I'm here today to oppose uh the house
bill uh
476 um I oppose this bill simply because
Freedom begins with our citizens right
for autonomy over their own bodies one
religion's belief system uh should never
be forced upon the
citizenry when one religious belief
system dictate state laws that is the
textbook definition of
theocracy New Hampshire's uh Bill of
Rights Article 2 States that we all have
certain natural essential and inherent
rights among which are enjoying and
defending life and Liberty acquiring
possessing and protecting property and
in a word of seeking and obtaining
happiness equality of rights under the
law shall not be denied or Abridged by
the state on account of race created
color
sex or national
origin autonomy over one's body is
natural essential and
inherent the sponsors of this of this
bill should be ashamed for bringing
forward legislation that directly depos
uh opposes our state bill um State Bill
of
Rights it seems our legislature has
forgotten that this is the Live Free or
Die State I call upon our law ERS to
fulfill its obligation to protect the
rights of New Hampshire's women and
throw this bill and others like it in
the trash sheep where they belong thank
you very much sir uh Janette Janelle
Hall and on Deck will be Aurora
weatherbe
good morning um and for the record my
name is Janelle Hall I am the executive
director of the equality Health Center
here in conquer and we're here to oppose
this
bill the equality Health Center is
located right down the street on Main
Street we are nonprofit Healthcare
facility serving all genders and
sexualities throughout New England for
over 50 years EHC has provide has been
providing individualized care with
compassion and respect
we are New Hampshire's longest standing
Abortion Center and very proud of
that I appreciate this opportunity to
submit written testimony for you all but
just wanted to have a few words this
morning as you heard our
professionals um they're trained they're
credentialed the medical staff is we're
affiliated with Dartmouth Health um to
provide safe expert and effective
outpatient services
this legislation is deeply unpopular
Granite Staters agree and polls confirm
that New Hampshire residents support
safe legal accessible Reproductive
Rights doctors and nurses attest that
politics have no place in the procedure
room EHC believes that government
overreach such as HB
476 intrudes and singles out singles out
clinics and that provide abortion
Services excuse me
it communicates a mistrust of and lack
of support for
facilities that patients actively seek
for their appropriate Health Care
abortion banss prevent Health Care
Providers from using their best
professional judgment and take away our
ability to make our personal medical
decisions decisions about private
reproductive Healthcare belong to a
patient in cons consultation with their
provider and not with the legis
legislature which should be only
concerned with the protection of our
citizens rights to receive comprehensive
Services I urge you to oppose HB 476 and
thank you for your time thank you very
much M if you have written time you you
pass it out okay all right that's fine
thank you um next is Aurora weatherbe
and on Deck will be Kayla Montgomery
good morning committee and uh fellow New
Hampshire residents my name is Miss
Aurora weatherbe I'm a resident of Derry
New Hampshire and have been for all of
the nearly 23 years of my life and I'm
here to testify against House Bill
476 HP 476 seeks to limit access to
necessary Medical Care not only does it
lower the term limit for abortion
significantly moving from 24 weeks to
only 15 but more frighteningly it does
not provide exceptions in the case of
rape or incest to be very clear under
this proposed law people can be forced
to carry two term pregnancies that
resulted from a rape worse yet they can
be forced to carry to term pregnancies
resulting from incest proponents of this
bill May say that in such cases those
people should simply receive an abortion
before 15 weeks yet this argument does
not take into account that many
incestuous and rape pregnancies are
coerced many times in these cases the
victim is impregnated against their own
will and afterwards coerced to keep that
child out of fear of Retribution from an
abusive partner this would include cases
of marital rape meaning abusive husbands
could force their wives to undergo the
traumatic process of carrying and
birthing an unwanted child all the while
suffering from continued abuse at the
hands of their
husband most frighteningly of all this
bill proposes a breach of patient
confidentiality for ing certain medical
procedures and their circumstances to be
reported to the Department of Health and
Human Services a department I will note
which was not listed in the contacted
agencies of the original draft of the
bill something which should be
incredibly concerning why is the
Department of Health and Human Services
who will be directly involved with the
enforcement of this bill not
contacted for comment by the sponsors
this is by far the most dangerous piece
of this bill New Hampshire is a state of
Live Free or Die and this state
certainly does not promote living free
and I think that only leaves one other
option in that motto now doesn't it as a
as a resident of Derry I would
specifically like to call out one of the
sponsors of this bill I don't know if
she's in this room representative
Katherine prud home O'Brien
representative as one of your own
constituents I must say I'm frankly
ashamed to be represented by one of the
sponsors of this bill all right um I
would also you're you're at your three
minutes three minutes yep so please wrap
up I'm proud to be from Derry I'm proud
to be from New Hampshire I love this
state but what I and so many others love
about this state is our freedom I'll say
it again our motto is Live Free or Die
and that's supposed to represent the
ideals of our people and this bill goes
against everything that our state stands
for so especially representative trip
who represents me I thank you man thank
you very
much going to call on Kayla Montgomery
next and uh on Deck will be
Christina Warner
Warner um I'm sorry and M mg do you have
written testimony or have you already
submitted online I did submit it that's
fine that's fine thank you uh good
morning members of the Judiciary
Committee my name is Kayla Montgomery
I'm the vice president of public affairs
for Planned Parenthood of Northern New
England and planed Parenthood action
fund um I want to thank the committee
for going ahead with this public hearing
uh regardless of uh the bill being
withdrawn it means a lot to the people
in this room regardless of what side of
the bill you're on so thank you uh for
having us today um I just want to use my
time today to talk a little bit about
General Health Care um unfortunately
Healthcare delivery is really in a tough
spot right now uh you have all seen the
headlines uh if you have received Health
Care in the last few months or few years
you know it is hard it is expensive it
can be extremely frustrating to get
health care for you or your loved ones
and there are many factors in play um
factors that none of us in this room are
going to be able to solve overnight we
know that these are much bigger than us
um but at planed Parenthood Northern New
England and in a postro world uh we as
an organization are incredibly Nimble
and we've been able to respond to
patients needs especially in the last
few years so I just want to give one
example um we recently be began to offer
new service in
Manchester um and that is vasectomies uh
interest in vasectomies
skyrocketed after Rowell um and that
hasn't changed that interest has
continued to grow uh thousands of
granite Staters come to us every year
hundreds every week and they come to us
because we are able to adapt and change
needs in this uh interesting time for
healthcare in this difficult time for
our Healthcare we are able to adapt
patient needs uh we work through the
challenges we work for the be barers we
can still a we can still offer
affordable health care it's timely and
compassionate and it's award-winning and
you don't have to take my word for it
because one in five American women have
been to a Planned Parenthood uh at some
point in her life
so why in this extremely precarious time
in healthare would the state make it
harder for us to provide health care
because that's what this bill does uh it
makes the health care situation worse
this bill has no purpose there's no
scientific or medical justification for
this arbitrary cutoff line 15 weeks is
months before the point of viability
which was recognized in decades of
medical research and referenced by the
Supreme Court and it does nothing but
put a barriers for granite Staters and
it prohibits highly qualified and
trained providers at hospitals and at
New Hampshire abortion clinics from
offering this care this bill is harmful
unnecessary and deeply unpopular and I
want to thank this committee again for
withdrawing this bill and I'm happy to
take any questions
all right any questions for this witness
seeing none thank you very much um next
is Christina warer and on Deck will
be uh
Aaron seamons I hope I got that right or
yes Aaron Seaman I believe yes please go
ahead ma'am thank you chairman and
members of the House Judiciary Committee
for the record my name is Christina
Warner and I serve as the New Hampshire
state director for Reproductive Equity
now and I will be speaking in opposition
to house bill 476 it is undeniable from
the abundance of testimony you have
heard including over 11,000 signin in
opposition to this proposal that this
ban on abortion at 15 weeks is out of
line with granted State values today I
want to Echo the concerns brought up by
providers and patients and we'll focus
my testimony on uplifting the evidence
we've seen on the harm to patients a
bill like this poses and the negative
maternal Health outcomes it would cause
a recent propublica investigation
examined the impacts of strict abortion
bans in States across the country it
found that in states with bands pregnant
women have bled to death contracted
sepsis and faced other serious infection
risks while waiting for providers
uncertain about their authority to offer
legal care as you've heard time and time
again this morning women are dying due
to the impacts of abortion banss with
similar exceptions for medical
emergencies as are proposed in HB 476
these heartbreaking stories clearly
demonstrate that in practice abortion
banss that include medical exceptions do
not work there is no and there will
never be a universal definition of the
distinct point at a pregnant person's
life becomes endangered research also
shows that states with abortion bands
pose a direct threat to maternal Health
outcomes states with bands are more
likely to have fewer maternity care
providers more deserts for maternity
care higher rates of maternal mortality
and infant death and higher overall
death rates for women of reproductive
age these findings should be of major
concern to the legislature which has
taken significant action in the past few
years to make progress on maternal and
infant Health outcomes the passage of HB
476 would be in direct opposition to the
bipartisan progress achieved for New
Hampshire moms and families through 2023
is momni bus and the potential success
of this session's babus 2.0 in closing
this bill is out of line with Granite
State values puts women and mothers at
risk and would imperal our state's
fragile maternal Health ecosystem
reproductive Equity now encourages your
opposition thanks you for withdrawing
the bill um and urges you to reject the
proposal if it moves forward thank you
very much uh Aaron Sean
and on Deck will be Matthew
beam and do you have written if you have
written testimony okay just you can you
can give your oral testimony and then
just pass it up along when you when
you're done thank you good morning
honorable members of the House Judiciary
Committee my name is Aon seens and I'm a
New Hampshire resident labor and
delivery nurse ER nurse and student
nurse Midwife I am here to oppose House
Bill HB
476 gational abortion bans hurt Granite
Staters and we don't want it I am proud
that as a New Hampshire resident and
healthcare worker who takes care of
women and families that abortion is safe
and legal in our state globally the
frequency of abortion is not correlated
by availability or legality which means
bands do not decrease abortion rates
they just make pregnancy more dangerous
throughout the country we have seen that
states with the strictest abortion laws
have the highest rates of maternal
deaths every pregnancy and every person
are unique and different and there is
simply no possible way to anticipate
every situation where a pregnant person
finds themselves making the incredibly
personal decision to seek an abortion
pregnancy can be complicated it is not a
health neutral state in fact the most
dangerous time in a person's life is
while they're pregnant it is
unpredictable when abortion care may be
needed even in a plan and wanted
pregnancy but in states with gational
banss it gets confusing what's
constitutes a maternal Health exemption
who decides this does the hospital
Ethics Committee have to be woken up in
the middle of the night to weigh in on
this decision does a judge have to be
contacted to declare that a person's
life is in danger how long does it take
how dead do they have to be have you
ever sat with a patient who was bleeding
out losing a desired pregnancy and
risking their own life and not being
able to do anything about it while their
providers scramble around to figure out
if they can act how hopeless and
terrifying that is I have uncertainty
causes delays in care and at no point in
pregnancy are politicians better experts
than a patient and their provider to
make these tough decisions abortion is
healthare it is common and it is
necessary to keep abortion easily
accessible and safe for the health of
all Granite Staters thank you thank you
very much um yeah um I'm sorry could I
ask a question of you of course uh thank
you for U letting me do that several
people have thanked this committee for
withdrawing the bill but my
understanding is that that is not an
accurate statement I understand that the
prime
sponsor has asked to withdraw the bill
but the bill is in fact before this
committee the committee has taken no AC
action and I don't think can take any
action since our obligation is to hold a
hearing um and follow procedures once a
bill has been filed and therefore um to
say that the committee has withdrawn the
bill is inaccurate am am I wrong on that
I think you're correct on that the as as
I said before as I understand the
procedure the bill is before this
committee um if if the prime sponsor and
all the co-sponsors want to withdraw it
at this stage
um uh that can only be done when if the
house votes to accept a withdrawal but
the bill you're you're correct it's Bill
is still before this committee but so
meanwhile there'd be no reason for us
not to finish this hearing finish that
open and hold the hearing on the non
gerain uh Amendment and then in fact for
this committee to vote on the non gerain
Amendment and the bill well that there
we will certainly hold a hearing on the
non- gerain amendment uh in terms of
voting on the bill um I I'm I'm not so
sure about that um but but you're right
we could do that I don't dispute that we
could do that whether we will or not
remains to be seen thank you very much
Mr chairman
one I'm sorry did somebody yeah I think
Caitlyn had a question too I was just
going to ask uh with regard to to uh
representative Smith's comments the one
thing I heard that I wanted to to be
crystal clear on uh because I had
understood from listening to the start
of this hearing that while of course the
withdrawal is not within our purview
that that goes to house session day that
this is reported as being a desire not
merely of the Prime sponsor but of all
the sponsors is is that correct my my
understanding my understanding is that
in order for a bill to be withdrawn even
when it can be done without it having to
go to the house for a vote and there is
some time period I think maybe it's
before the bill has been scheduled for a
hearing the prime sponsor and all the
co-sponsors May withdraw the bill yeah
just on their own I'm with you on the
house rule I'm just simply asking
whether we know uh whether the other
co-sponsors are of similar mind to the
prime sponsor my understanding is that
they are but um I'll the other
co-sponsors have signed
off and representative kutab did you
have something you all right all right
so Matthew uh Bean beam I'm sorry and on
Deck will be Kurt
wolper good morning thank you for having
me sure my name is Matthew beam I'm a
resident of
samton uh I'm also an ordain Minister uh
which appears to put me at a
disadvantage in this
debate
um and I'm just going to speak more
generally here on abortion just for the
record I guess I was just asked to speak
a couple of days ago my views on this
topic have evolved over time and uh I
certainly can't claim to have any moral
High Ground in any of this I'm just a
guy in search of the truth like
you I do know uh I've been thinking
about human history a lot lately and
there have been times in human history
when those who had power were able to
oppress or exterminate another group of
people and one of the ways they were
able to do this was to classify that
group of people as not fully
human American slaveholders could do
what they did because Africans were
classified as not fully
human the Nazis could do what they did
because they reclassified the Jewish
people as not fully
human and I see us doing it
again um there's an old quote attributed
to Mark Twain which says history doesn't
repeat itself but it often Rhymes um so
I want to be clear here I'm not saying
that people are Nazis or that they're
like slaveholders I'm just saying that
history has recurring patterns and we
tend to be shortsighted and I'm seeing
it
today uh I think one day history is
going to come back around on this just
like it has in the
past one day these babies will win the
fight for human rights probably not
today based on what I'm hearing maybe
not in 50 years but one day they
will I realize it's not politically
expedient for most of you to pass a bill
like this um it was not politically
expedient to speak up for the rights of
Africans in the 1800s and it was not
politically expedient to speak up for
the rights of Jews in Germany in the
40s but uh I remind you that your public
office isn't merely about political
expediency it is about what's doing
what's right in the long
term these are human beings I think most
of us here know it and history will show
it to be true thank you for your time
thank you very much sir uh uh former
representative Kurt walper uh and then
on Deck will be
[Music]
Kathleen CLA
uh thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee it's a pleasure to be back
in the room again glad even on this side
of the
table I I sit here I'd say I stand here
well I'm here today to say this I serve
the Living God the creator of the
universe The Giver of
Life and the only owner of every life
that he creates God loves everyone of
his
creatures the Supreme
Court not not what I'd call a religious
organization when the issue of the
famous Infamous which I started that
year on Ro versus Wade
decision did so on the basis of the
inability to tell
what the object of the abortion
was they claimed they could not identify
when human life began and consequently
they would say you can do abortion today
we can identify
when we know very precisely in a b
biological way when it
begins according to the Supreme Court in
1973 if we knew
that abortion would already be
constitutional under the 14th Amendment
of the United States
Constitution but they said we're not
going there and they
didn't medical
ethics So today we're
here medical ethics up until the the
abortion era
prohibited any abortive Fati or any
practitioner of healthcare from
assisting in any way in the death of a
pre-born child they prohibited it of
course they had to change the hypocritic
go to line with what you want to call
current practice and so it has been
changed and most of the providers that
we've heard talk
today never heard of that orth never
took that oath but they all used
to we've heard a lot about mental heal
maternal health care I don't know what's
wrong with the Medical Health Care
system of the United States what I do
know
is that in countries like England and
Sweden and France and many others in the
European region and around the
world where the standard for abortion
care is 15 weeks or
less have higher maternal success rates
lower M maternal mortality than in the
United
States so if in fact the these
laws do increase inter uh maternal
mortality I'm thinking the problem is
with the health care system and not with
the law because your your time limit is
up I'd ask you if you could finish up
please thank
you abortion is a temporary a permanent
solution to a temporary problem it
should be under the Constitution and
certainly under my religion
illegal I urge you to support the Bill
thank you thank thank you very much
Kathleen Clan I think I've got that
right and on Deck will be Shawn
Rogers Kathleen Clark okay that uh if
from yeah yeah okay good come on
up thank you
hi so my name is Kath Clark I live in
samton I'm a nurse and I'm the founder
of a nursing advocacy business a women's
Fertility Center and a prospective
holistic health center um I've come here
today to tell you that I almost didn't
exist um The Story Goes that my father
had a previous marriage before he
married my mother um they were married
she wanted children and after marrying
they saw those two pink lines so when my
mother went to tell my father that she
was pregnant um she was met with anger
betrayal h how could you do this to me
um he was scared he had a lot of fear he
was scared that he couldn't be a good
father scared that he wouldn't be enough
scared to bring a baby into the world
after the marriage you know his first
marriage wasn't successful um so after
that reaction my mother in obedience to
my father said I'll go find out so she
went she went to the clinic and she
found out um she gathered information
pamphlets brochures she was educated on
what would happen What To Expect and she
left that clinic and she went to my
father and she said I'm so sorry I don't
know where this leaves our marriage but
I cannot do it so she spent the next
nine months of her pregnancy um with her
husband not acknowledging her pregnancy
whatsoever um she says that he didn't
acknowledge it until I was on my way out
but I did come out I showed up into the
world and do you want to know what
happened he fell in love like all
parents do in their own way he fell in
love with me and he forgot all that fear
and all the doubt and all his upset I
became his world and he raised me to be
a strong resilient woman with a tackle
anything attitude I lived every day
feeling cherished and loved now I have
three beautiful children of my own but
what if what if he had been stronger in
his convictions or my mother had been
weaker what if she had said yes in the
clinic that day the answer I wouldn't be
here and the countless lives that I've
touched in my nursing business business
my family life my friends who have
reached out when they needed a shoulder
to cry on would all be worse off for me
not being here and it doesn't just stop
there the killing of a baby in the womb
doesn't just stop at that one fetus the
baby in the womb is full of potential
and what ifs if my mother had said yes
my own children wouldn't exist and how
those children have impacted lives in a
positive way already in their short life
that's the thing um you know the light
that lives in people's Souls has
positive Ripple effects on an infinite
number of people and things can you
think of a single person that you know
who has never had a single positive
impact on anyone or anything in their
whole lives the answer is of course no
it's an
impossibility
alternately if my mother had said yes to
abortion that yes would have left a dark
mark and an abusive mark on my mother's
life and soul and that has Ripple
effects too all of us who work in the
women's health space can attest to the
Grave emotional wounds your time your
time we is up so I ask you to please sum
up so what will you do today will you
choose Darkness lies and abuse will you
let fear speak louder than hope or will
you choose love truth and light thank
you thank you very much Shan Rogers and
on Deck will be oh boy WR do you have oh
do you have written testimony ma'am Miss
CLK can we have your testimony thank you
thank you on deck wow
um
Kylie Bearer from someone from
Bedford please go ahead sir oh thank you
so uh I just wanted to relay my
experiences so when my wife was pregnant
with her first son uh she began to make
a lot of predictions about his
personality and how he would be and and
like really specific things uh like what
foods he liked and how active he was if
you liked to dance like all all these
kinds of things needless to say I
thought it was bunk I just thought she
was I just thought she was um just being
silly but uh after he was born and after
he started to grow up I saw all of her
predictions come true and what
is especially pertinent here is that the
prediction started when she was about
like 12 in between 12 and 16 weeks so
like 12 13 14 weeks and so um based on
that based on my experience is you know
I would say that a fetus even that young
uh is not just some unfeeling organism
it is a person and its life shouldn't be
forfeit so easily now in regards to the
medical providers that have all come out
uh I would just say that if you feel
that strongly the thrust of these laws
is mainly against unnecessary abortions
obviously medical necessary things are
medically necessary and so if you feel
that strongly about it what I would
suggest you do is just write up your own
guidelines for
what exceptions should be made because
the legislators don't know they don't
know your profession so why don't you
guide them through it and then you might
be able to come up with a more
bipartisan uh solution to a problem
that's obviously very divisive that's
what I have to say thank you very much
thank you very much sir um again K
Kylie Farah Farah and on Deck will be
Francis
clean um
I may not be pronouncing
this Carly findes that's
it thank you and on Deck Francis
Klean hi good morning morning my name is
Carly fines I'm 28 years old and my
residence in Hometown is Bedford New
Hampshire I'm from a family of Jewish
doctors in reformed Judaism we are
taught that life begins at Birth I
repeat myself birth not conception if
anything
anything happens that puts the mother in
danger rape incest fatal fetal anomaly
septic uterus cancer miscarriage any of
that
happens in reformed Jewish law we are
taught that she has the option if not
the obligation to save herself and
terminate the fetus especially in
scenarios where she already has children
postpartum that she has obligations to
either way she regardless of decision
and outcome she has spared any and all
judgment from or vilification from her
peers her as is her
doctor the that's the main problem with
these abortion laws and restrictions
medical events like which like the
forces of nature have their own timeline
they don't care about human-made laws so
something can go wrong long after the
15we deadline and it could turn a
miracle into a
tragedy it's if if you choose to vote
Yes on this bill please note that what
you are doing is hermetically sealing
off the emergency exit and taking away
resources from women who really need it
I certainly would not go into an
abandoned building because it isn't safe
and I certainly would not jump out of a
plane without a parachute for that exact
same reason as reformed Jews our orders
are go forth and multiply why how are we
supposed to do that if we're not
safe this is the main reason I'm
choosing to remain childree because
Parenthood and and motherhood in America
is just not safe or sustainable anymore
I repeat myself if you care about life
at all you would vote no on this bill I
will not be taking questions thank you
very much ma'am Francis cleer Klean and
on Deck will be Jessica
Sergeant do you have written
T oh
well hi hi um my name is Francis ker and
I'm from Bo um so I um I'm here in
opposition to the proposed legislation
um I'm registered nurse I've been
working for uh 44 years taking care of
patients and um this ban will definitely
harm
women and I don't speak um H in
hypotheticals um I speak in reality and
with
experience um I would also like to bring
to your attention that not every child
unfortunately is
adoptable um I I work at a safety net
Hospital uh I am that person that cares
for the
unadoptable um people with devastating
intellectual and phys physical
disabilities when they come into the
hospital um I also take care of these
children when they are no longer
children when they're in their 60s and
70s and their parents are dead and they
have no one um it would be nice if
people would adopt these people but they
usually don't um unfortunately that's
reality um women need the freedom to
consult with their Physicians and health
care providers to discuss medical
options then they need to have the
freedom to make the choices that are
right for them as
individuals um secondly I'm here as a
mother and a grandmother to protect the
rights of my daughters and
granddaughters um they are afraid that
they might need medical care and might
not be able to get the care that they
need um my 11-year-old granddaughter
Natalya asked me to be here today to
protect her
rights um one of my daughters is a
surgeon
and she's fearful um for her patients uh
lastly I'm here as a Jew um Judaism
teaches that life begins a birth not
conception it also teaches that pregnant
a pregnant
woman uh if they are in any way
negatively affected by the pregnancy
whether that be physical emotional
psychological Financial she is permitted
to terminate her
pregnancy um so if this um OS
legislation was passed um it would
actually violate um a Jewish person's
right to practice their faith thank you
very much for listening to me thank you
very much ma'am um Jessica sergeant and
on Deck is Kevin Gan
gag hi my name is Jessica Sergeant um
I'm sitting here representing myself um
I sit here in a incredible seat of
position of privilege because my husband
does support and prioritize me that he
got of a sectomy so that when we decided
to be childree that I didn't have to
bear the brunt of reproduction I got to
get off birth control because it was
making me so Su so suicidal that he had
to hide things in our home um
constitutionally we are able to not have
to participate in any sort of religion
and that also means that if people are
able to um with that
laws that dictate my life should not
have to um have any sort of religious
undertones um I also believe that
corpses should not have more rights to
body autonomy than a living breathing
human being who can tell you what they
do and don't want to do with their body
I also shouldn't have to make this
argument to men in this room who do not
know that my urethra is not in my vagina
and also to women who are being wolves
and sheep's clothing by sitting here and
um
just throwing their their fellow
people to the
wolves
um if people can tell you what they do
and don't want to do then that that
should be your right it's it's Medical
Health Care at the basis of it we have
bastardized abortion when it's just the
medical terminology we don't bastardize
chemotherapy or any sort of therapy
along those lines that's all I have to
say about it thank you very much ma'am
you also said you had written oh did you
did you say you have written testimony
you don't okay all right Kevin Gagner on
Deck will be uh Michelle
Flynn oh that's fine man sure that's
fine thank you what's your can I just
ask your
name Robin Coswell thank
you hi hi good morning um my name is
Kevin gagen uh just going to State the
obvious here to exercise my first
amendment I know there's been discussion
between uh you know people of faith and
no faith so I just wanted to uh forewarn
the listeners in the year of Our Lord
January 27th
2025 I am testifying to the truth the
truth is our lord Jesus was not aborted
in the womb of his
mother he was born of the Virgin Mary
and became man was crucified buried and
rose on the third day it will come again
to judge the living and the
dead our calendar in this bill
acknowledges our
Lord our state of New Hampshire's
Constitution and the United States of
America's Constitution acknowledges our
Lord I pray that all of you people of
New Hampshire respect life from the
moment of conception to Natural death we
the people of New Hampshire would would
not be here if we were
aborted so I'm here to support and
defend
life and potentially HB
476 this is a matter of life or
death death is not the worst of evils
however killing marks number five of the
top
10 a abortion is the only surgery you're
not supposed to
survive it's easy to be pro-choice when
you are not the one being
killed New Hampshire citizens were born
to be
free If Only They were free to be
born our biological parents did not play
politics with their decision to let us
live free and not die
thank you thank you very much you stated
you have written testimon yeah I I
emailed it you guys you you emailed it
okay thank you Michelle Flynn and on
Deck will be Shan
Foster good morning it's morning still
my name is Michelle Flyn I'm from
Bedford New Hampshire and I'm actually
Dr Flynn I'm uh Internal Medicine phys
pH currently retired taking care of my
family so I am here in support of the
bill and in support of life this all
became personal for me during my
training um in my third year of
residency I had an infinite home and a
husband who was a student I was the
breadwinner and I was in the ICU
rotation after rotation um where I
didn't get a lot of sleep and I didn't
take care of myself very well but I
started to notice I had symptoms of
pregnancy with a less than one-year-old
at home I was the bread winner and I had
a job lined
up so when I finished my rotations and
finished my training I got an ultrasound
and um expecting a little liab bean
maybe with a heartbeat and instead I was
really shocked that there was a fully
formed baby sucking his thumb and his
time was about 15 weeks um
gestation and I thought I have a job I I
have all this responsibility should I
terminate the pregnancy but honestly as
a doctor looking at that that was a
sentient human being and I couldn't
dismember him he's now 30 years old and
he's an engineer he makes works on
artificial hearts and is
married things worked out for me at that
time but I just had to really come to
grips with the personhood of my child
and I'm here to just speak up for the
personhood of the of the children of the
babies that are in utero because I do
believe they are persons and as a
physician I want to say I believe that
they are their other Solutions I
understand there's some babies that are
very very sick but as a doctor and as a
mother I don't believe in taking the
life of a sick person but treating them
treating them with compassion and with
nurturing and with love and I feel that
the abortion
mindset makes life
expedient and denies the reality that
suffering exists in every one of our
lives and it would be nice to control
all of suffering and control all of
illness but we can't and I feel like we
need compassionate solutions to this uh
two sick babies in the womb that don't
involve in my mind taking their life um
so I just want to say thank you for
letting me speak today and I want it to
be a voice for The Unborn thank you
thank you very much ma'am
Shan Foster and on Deck will be
Emily uh
zazano good morning chairman Lynn and
members of the committee I'm Sean Foster
pastor of the crossing Life Church in
Windham New Hampshire I represent a
large church that considers life from
from conception sacred in fact one of my
son's best friends from a family who's
also been part of the church since since
his birth was born a day past the 24
week Mark um doctors told the mother
that there was no hope I had the
privilege of walking with them through a
very very difficult
situation um the mother to compound
things was also not able to take care of
the baby so the grandmother stepped up
and actually raised Caleb he was one
pound 9 ounces and fit in the palm of
his mother's hand two decades later he's
an amazing musician who serves on our
Church's worship team he's in the
process of joining the United States
Army we've heard from many people today
who spoke on moral medical psychological
factors a recent poll by data orbital um
reflects that the majority of people in
New Hampshire are in agreement for this
15we bill I know that many of you face
other factors of consideration beyond
the simple issue of the
bill today though I would like to appeal
to you all regardless of these factors
and
conditions uh that you'd allow this bill
to go to the floor for the vote to be
given opportunity of the democratic
process for a
vote since there is a large constituency
in New Hampshire that wants it to be
heard please allow your constituents in
New Hampshire to be heard I want to
thank you all for being willing to serve
our state and thank you for your
consideration is supporting HB 476 thank
you sir um Emily uh zazano and on Deck
will be Meg
overa and I hope I pronounced your name
correctly so close all right thanks uh
good morning uh my name is Dr Emily zjo
and I ask you to oppose HB
476 15 weeks is an arbitrary date
meaning if someone received new
information on the first day of the 15th
week they could be banned from an
abortion as a doctor and as a patient I
understand just how different every
pregnancy is I'm a pediatric Emergency
Physician a mother of two living
children and I have had two abortions it
was my first pregnancy and very much
wanted my husband and I were shocked and
thrilled when our first scan at 12 weeks
showed two
babies however the ultrasound also
showed I had a uterine anomaly a
potentially life-threatening condition
the Twins were in two different areas of
my uterus more studies suggested I was
safe and we would have our baby
girls that took a few
weeks we chose names I marked the date
on my calendar when they would be 29
weeks and hopefully likely to
survive at 16 weeks and 4 days pregnant
I woke up in severe pain it hurt to
breathe I was hospitalized wi while we
learned more my husband and I sat in a
dark room where monitors showed the
ultrasound images turned on during happy
scans turned off during the sad ones
they were off for
ours the news was worse than we could
imagine the left side was a previously
unrecognized rudimentary horn and the
uterine wall had ruptured in two places
this fetus had no chance my womb was
literally
broken on the right side the baby Had A
congenital heart defect which would
require surgery and functioning lungs to
survive if she could make it to
viability in my broken
womb these findings changed everything
to save my life I needed surgery and one
of my daughters inside needed to be
removed after surgery the fetus on the
right was still
there but it was clear that allowing the
pregnancy to continue would put me at a
huge risk
2 weeks later at 19 weeks pregnant we
went to Boston for the appointment the
day before the DNC the
abortion we were there for medical care
we were there to save my life we were
there because this was the most
appropriate decision for our family my
abortions saved my life allowed me to
have more children and allowed me to
continue my work to save your children's
lives Gran Staters and their medical
providers need all options available to
them without government
interference people need to make medical
decisions with their providers and loved
ones without the state placing arbitrary
limitations every pregnancy is unique
the complexities and situations that can
arise are innumerable ma'am your your
time is up I'd ask you to please finish
up if you my summary statement is this
one size fits all laws such as this
abortion ban simply do not work Granite
Staters and their families deserve
support and options
not laws like this thank you very much
uh Meg over and next
is Jake Barry on
Deck do you have Britain testim oh I'm
sorry um I can email it and just have it
digital okay that's fine thank you WR
Tes thank
you I'm sorry go ahead please my name is
me overbaugh I'm a New Hampshire native
a resident of Campton and I been a
practicing pharmacist for the last 15
years I am here to oppose House Bill 476
this bill is yet another attempt to
curil the autonomy of New Hampshire
residents it is scientifically
inaccurate and it is an attempt to solve
a problem that does not exist it uses
medically incorrect language plainly in
its title which is indicative of a
dedication to protecting Dogma rather
than protecting
citizens I would also like to take this
opportunity to remind everyone in this
room that we do not live in a theocracy
and and if you have religious
convictions that those are yours and
yours
alone um firstly the American College of
OB Obstetricians and gynecologists or
AOG recommends the removal of the term
elective abortion from any policies and
regulations and Advocates that all
abortions are considered medically
indicated the reasons patients choose to
terminate pregnancies are diverse and
complex every abortion is performed for
a therapeutic reason again that is from
an AOG guidance statement from this year
currently there's an abortion ban at 24
weeks in New Hampshire with exception
for the pregnant person's health or
fetal nonviability the currently
proposed legislation seeking to ban late
term abortion which again is not a
medically accurate term would restrict
that banned to 15 weeks according to
National Data from 2022 from the CDC
92.8% of abortions are performed at less
than or equal to 13 weeks gestations as
others have already stated only
approximately 1% of abortions
occur after 21 weeks dropping the
Restriction down to 15 weeks will only
set a precedent that abortion rights are
made of sandstone rather than granite
and can be re eroded easily over time
with little pre PR pressure applied I
must again refer to the AOG statement on
abortion rights which opposes
gestational age banss according to AOG
these banss sometimes but not always
include vaguely and arbitrarily defined
exceptions that contribute to the
confusing legal landscape for patients
and Healthcare professionals there is no
just state ational age ban that
increases the safety of abortion
procedures in fact gestational age bans
create unnecessary barriers that make it
more likely that patients may need to
seek abortion Care at later gational
ages again that is from ACOG I am tired
of having to fight for my right for
bodily autonomy and the autonomy of my
children and my family members and
friends every legislative cycle how many
male members of the House of
Representatives are kept up at Night by
the concern that their young Sons will
have fewer rights to their own body than
they did why is our state motto Live
Free or Die it feels like a gimmick
rather than a solemn commitment to the
right to live without government
overreach into deeply private and
personal decisions if this law is an
argument for the protection of children
then I would like to remind you that the
number one killer of children in this
country is gun violence in the current
Administration your three minutes is up
I'd ask you to please finish up sure um
I would encourage everyone here says
they are four children to call the White
House every single day to reinstate that
office of gun violent prevention I would
also like to is there another is there
another hearing for the amendment you're
at yes there will be heing amend I'll be
back have do you have written testimony
I'll have to email it okay that's
fine uh Jake Barry and on Deck will be
attorney Ian y
yeah I'm not going to do
that yes
so Jake Barry is Jake Barry
here oh all right so uh Jake Barry's not
here then attorney Ian yout and on Deck
will be
Courtney oh Courtney heed oh Courtney
Reed yeah Courtney Reed
yes Mr uitt Mr chairman and members of
the committee Ian huitt Council for
Cornerstone in support of House Bill
476 two points for the committee one on
the rationale behind 15 weak banss and
two on how a 15we line could affect a
long-term settlement of this issue in
New Hampshire in the dobs against
Jackson case chief justice Roberts wrote
a separate concurrence where he said the
court should uphold a row case framework
while also upholding a 15we ban and his
argument was that the core right in
Rowan Casey was always about Choice
which 15 weeks provides the court has
always said that at a certain point a
woman who fails to act consents to the
state's intervention on behalf of the
child and he wrote quote 15 weeks is
well beyond the point at which nearly
all women are aware that they are
pregnant most Granite Staters share that
same intuition that's why people's
opinions in this state on abortion drop
off sharply around 15 weeks about 70% of
the state supports unlimited elective
abortion before 15 weeks after 15 weeks
if you do polling asking about specific
policies and not just abortion
generically up or down 60 to 64% of the
state agree with Banning elective
abortion after 15 with only 32 to 34%
disagreeing most regular Granite Staters
see 15 weeks as an adequate window to
make a choice secondly a lot of the
polarizing rhetoric around the 24-week
ban was a result of cynical
misinformation such as many people
describing it in the media as an
abortion ban with no exceptions for rape
period that would not be the case under
under this bill because even the
opponents of the bill need to
differentiate it from the existing law
in order to mobilize their supporters
against it and in fact we can already
see people referring to it as the 15we
ban two things would happen if this bill
moved forward through the Democratic
process one is that the Bill's opponents
would actually diffuse the energy on
their own side because they would be
highlighting the moderate nature of this
bill and their own unpopular extremism
and secondly through this process people
on the opposite poll would come to see
that the idea of going even further than
this bill bill is not viable in this
state under this political system so
this bill could affect a long-term
settlement between Granite Staters of
deeply held and divided views in a way
that most people of the state if not
most of the political class agrees with
if the committee is doing any questions
today I'm happy to answer any questions
for this wedness I have one yes
representative
far so I I know that today uh we have
heard from quite a lot of uh folks
testifying including some medical
practitioners testifying that there are
very significant defects that cannot be
uh practicably determined before the 15
to 24- we window uh and that some of
those defects including some of the
heart defects that were described are
such as to uh have a an extremely
negative impact uh on the child's uh
future life does Cornerstone have a
point of view not on whether or not
knowing about those defects uh ought to
change a
decision uh on that child uh and whether
or not to abort that child but do you
have a point of view on whether or not
it is in fact impracticable to
satisfactorily diagnose those defects
prior to 15
weeks we do we did not take a position
though on the addition of the broad
fetal anomalies incompatible with life
exception that's included in our current
law and that exception is reiterated in
this law I'd also point out that we have
a very broad Health exception in the
state almost all the cases you've heard
about today from Deep Red States like
Texas are in states where there is
effectively only a life exception New
Hampshire has a very broad exception for
any serious risk to the mother's
physical health uh which is the same
exception the court required under R
casy existed in States like
Massachusetts for many years until
around 2020 and that same broad help
exception is reiterated in this law so
the kinds of situations we see in Texas
would not arise here in New Hampshire
thank you other questions for this wit
seeing none thank you very much sir
Courtney Reed and on Deck will be uh
Jean uh
mcginness thank you chair Lyn and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Courtney Reid I as
policy Advocate with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and I'm speaking in opposition
to this bill uh as we've observed today
uh and in numerous polls we know that
Granite Staters overwhelmingly support
the notion that everyone has the freedom
to make their own decisions about their
bodies and their Futures and that that
this includes the decision to have an
abortion and I want to express thanks to
the sponsors of this bill and the
committee for their perception uh to
this opposition to the underlying
bill because HB
476 if enacted would undermine our
country's and our state's long-standing
values to protect personal autonomy by
stripping away this fundamental right in
real world situations with cruel
consequences we've heard many stories
today about the devastating effects of
abortion bans even with exceptions like
um I would just outline a few uh since
2022 over 100 pregnant women in distress
across the country were mistreated or
were turned away from emergency rooms
because of bans in Florida a 15-week
pregnant woman miscarried after being
negligently discharged despite having a
dangerous ultrasound she later needed
emergency care and was placed on a
ventilator and spent 6 days
recovering in Georgia Amber
28 years old died after being denied an
abortion despite the state's medical
emergency
exemptions the state's maternal
mortality review deemed her death was
preventable we know that the inability
to access abortion laws not only leaves
uh women suffering from these horrible
Health consequences but that they're
more likely to experience poverty
they're more likely to stay with abusive
partners and that these bands have shown
known to be correlated with poor
maternal Health outcomes across the
board and we've heard and we know that
doctors are bound to Medical ethics but
that HB 476 does not accommodate for all
of the variances in individual
pregnancies and it would make it
difficult for doctors to act in the best
interests of their
patients and that's because this bill
hovers severe criminal liabilities over
doctors when they're exercis ing
discretion um it puts them in an
impossible situation where they would
exercise an abundance of caution and act
against their best medical judgment to
avoid
criminalization this will not only
endanger patients but it will deter
future clinicians from practicing in the
state in fact in 2021 when New
Hampshire's current abortion ban was
introduced we heard from providers that
the criminal penalties would
disincentivize them to work in three
minutes is up I'd ask you to please wrap
up thank you uh just on a final note we
know that the choice to have an abortion
is a private important decision that
should be free from critical
interference and uh our residents
deserve access to care when they need it
so again we urge legislators to vote in
opposition to this Bill thank you thank
you do you have a written question thank
you so much yes if you could bring that
uh so Jean mcginness and on De will
be shot
sh
shasana
shasana Kelly shashana Kelly and so you
know what I just just uh before we hear
from the next witness I just for the
members of the committee um we don't
require a quorum for the hearing and I
know you know a lot of you have been
here for a while so if some of you I'm
not it's completely up to you but if
some of you want to go get something to
eat um you know there'll there'll be
some of us that will hang in there the
one thing I would emphasize though is
please
do not leave for the day I mean I would
ask you to be back by I don't know 12:45
or so because the I the question of
whether we will EXA either this bill or
anything else um is is yet to be decided
and I'm I I as far as whether we would
exec anything else I need to talk to uh
the ranking member about that um but
that what I'm saying is don't leave for
the day if you want to get something to
eat go now but don't leave for the day
all right thank you I'm sorry go ahead
please thank you chairman I hope none of
you leave my name is Gan mcginness and I
oppose this
bill um I'm here as a citizen as a
grandmother um and as actually a citizen
of New Hampshire who is female and I
hear a lot of people talking about
citizens of New Hampshire but it's
really the women of New Hampshire who
are going to be affected by this bill
and I don't understand how a group of of
politicians who have been elected in a
state that really believes in Live Free
or Die would decide that half of the
population should have a a decision made
that is not theirs uh a medical decision
for me has been about choice and I
respected that law that said I could
choose whether I wanted to have an
abortion or not and yes I was a person
who was pregnant before I thought I
should be but I got to choose and his
name's Joshua and he's 40 and he just
had twins so I have Evelyn and Ronan now
as well and all of these decisions to me
just seem so strange that you do not
trust women enough to make their own
decision these are very difficult
complex decisions for women to make they
should not be legislated by law they are
a moral decision they are a decision
about belief they are decision about
economy they are decision about your
life and your your future life and the
medicine that you're using when this law
passed 50 years ago when I was quite
young that it was to save women's lives
and as many of the medical professionals
have told you you'll be essentially
letting women die again or find ways for
them to get rid of fetuses that they
don't want because it's a power struggle
when someone is taken by another human
and usually it's a man who takes that
person and violates them so to let this
law even come into a discussion is
shocking to me and I realize it's only
about a hundred years ago that I as a
woman got a right to vote I believe it
was 1920 so it's not that long and not
only that I didn't have a right to
property prior to that as well so I
would hope that we would not go back in
time and go back to a time when I was
very young I was able to grow up during
a time that I had the right to make that
decision and that decision I made was a
choice because I had the power to do it
and it was my faith and my belief and my
ability as a human as a woman to say yes
I can make this choice
his name is Joshua and I would like
every other woman in this state to have
that right to make that choice thank you
thank you uh shashana I'm I'm sorry I
Kelly I'm sorry thank you and next on
Deck will be uh uh Caitlyn
Matthews I was gonna say good morning
but it's almost afternoon say this
afternoon um my name is shos Kelly I'm
an older woman at large in NASA um I'm
mom and a small business owner um and I
am here in opposition of this bill as an
you you're you may sit down if you'd
like please we used to have chairs put
one up
honey um so as an elected official I
know what it's like to be in your shoes
I'm usually on the other side um of this
microphone and so I'm here uh to remind
you that you took an oath to be fair
thoughtful and open to listen to both
sides and to use sound judgment when you
make any and all decision ISS on behalf
of the people of New Hampshire a 15we
abortion ban will have dire consequences
women will die doctors will be unable to
give the life-saving reproductive health
care that so many need I ask you to
think deeply about your role as a
representative of the people voting Yes
means you believe that you should be in
the room with a woman and her health
care provider as she makes some of the
most intimate decisions of her life
not only that but this is deeply
unpopular poll after poll shows that
Granite Staters do not want a ban I
brought my daughter Elsa here with me
and I brought her here today because I
wanted you to look her in the eyes as
you consider your vote look at this
young woman she's just
13 and if you vote Yes know that you
were telling her with one word that you
believe you are a better J of her judge
of her reproductive health needs than
her doctor look in her eyes as you tell
her with one vote that the life of some
future unborn baby baby matters more
than her own thank you thank you very
much ma'am uh Caitlyn Matthews and on
Deck is Jonathan
Kimble good afternoon to the committee
and thank you for the opportunity to
speak today my name is Caitlyn Matthews
and I am here to oppose HB
476 I'm the chief operating officer at
the Second Step a nonprofit domestic
violence
organization many people who have
testified today have discussed the OB
deserts and the ramification of banss to
accessing Healthcare I want to speak
about the intersection of domestic
violence and abortion
access we know that any changes to the
power and control Dynamic associated
with intimate partner violence
significantly increases the risk of
lethality pregnancy is an increasingly
significant change to this
Dynamic domestic violence including
abuse that involves reproductive
coercion frequently results in
non-consensual pregnancies restrictive
abortion access exacerbates domestic
violence resulting in increased
isolation vulnerability health risks and
delays in seeking help by passing this
bill and entertaining similarly
restrictive bills there will undoubtedly
be an increase in domestic violence and
thus creating a situation in which
survivors cannot feel safe coming
forward to seek help I oppose HB 476 and
if you support domestic violent
survivors I implore you to oppose this
bill as well thank you thank you very
much mayor next uh Jonathan Kimble and
on Deck will be Sue Allen
hello everybody uh thank you so much for
uh being here today um my name is
Jonathan Kimble I'm 24 years old I'm a
lifelong resident of uh Hampton New
Hampshire and I'm in favor of uh Bill
476 um but opposed to the amendment uh
that's being proposed as well um
specifically uh speaking to elected
officials who are bringing forward the
amendment uh this bill is the reason
your constituents elected you this bill
is a turning point for the fate of The
Unborn in New Hampshire and to a
significant extent our nation as the
last purple state with uh a chance to
continue the fight for life you have a
choice to stand up for what is right and
push this progress forward or you can
bend the knee to your own political gain
if this amendment passes it may be the
last nail in the coffin for the New
Hampshire right to
life as a nation we look back with
horror and disgust at the injustices of
slavery where the lives and rights of
millions of men and women were violated
those violations occurred because the
strong arbitrarily stripped Humanity
from their co- image bearers a chief
player in the institution of slavery
were the politicians who looked the
other way for political gain those men
who chose their own immediate gain over
their lives of the over the lives of the
innocent have eternally tarnished
shameful memory a with a real chance to
take ground against slavery is proposed
and the Very ones who elect to push it
through amend it to merely track
data um in 2025 the strong continued to
arbitrarily strip Humanity from the weak
as melanin determined Humanity in our
nation's past now age determines
Humanity do not let yourself suppose
that we are any better than our
ancestors or that we have progressed we
are fighting the same battle we were
fighting 200 years ago but with
different victims and 10 times the
number of victims you're being lied to
there is no good future for those who
choose death do not seek the approval of
those who would tell you to sacrifice
the lives of The Unborn they're making
promises to you um that you will gain
from compromising the truth but um my
friends they are lying to you someday
our nation will look back on abortion
with the with the same abhorrence and
shame that we see slavery now the
dehumanizing slaughter of the innocent
that our nation engages in will be seen
for what it is barbaric idolatrous child
sacrifice today you have the choice to
be counted among those who played along
with this Abomination for political gain
or to use your influence to do what is
right to do what you were elected to do
you may for a short time benefit
politically for destroying this bill but
that will be no Comfort to you when you
stand before God and it will be no
Comfort to your generational reputation
when the wicked murder of children is
finally blotted out of this nation
choose carefully whom you will serve
your constituents are watching but most
importantly God Is Watching thank you
thank you very much sir right right on
the three minute all right Sue Allen is
up next and on Deck will be
Katherine uh
Tucker excuse me
sir sir who just Jonathan do you have
written testimony that you want I
submitted it online coup sheets that's
fine thank you hi good afternoon my name
is Sue Allen I live in
Hollis I many years ago had a
spontaneous abortion uh this is the kind
where with only a couple hours of uh
warning I was holding a perfectly
formed baby in my hand I was 16 weeks
pregnant and the doctor told me that the
baby measured at 12 and a half weeks now
my testimony is I want to emphasize is
that I've seen and held the baby which
uh further research told me that um
around 12 weeks is when the babies are
perfectly formed um they they they don't
look like a space alien um and I I can
tell you with my own eyes it took me
years to get over the shock of it I'd
speak of it at inappropriate times
um in any case uh the point I want to
make here um is according to the numbers
that this proposal for a 15we ban which
I support is that uh as been already
testified there's um uh 95 plus I forget
the numbers uh um abortions are already
uh between the 8 and 12 week Point um
also to try to explain to you why
there's this sentiment
of 60
plus% I forget what was testified of
General support that will after uh after
15 weeks the majority of us in New
Hampshire don't don't support this well
I want to say that it's a sense of the
humanity of the the baby at that point
of development that I can tell you that
I saw with my own eyes so what I
encourage you to recognize here is that
what's at stake is life and death
decisions over a
developed baby um there's an issue among
um many women who are like me Mothers uh
and and me myself at my younger stage
where we have to choose our health
providers carefully because of the
bizarre situation of being told this
gets reported among women that well I I
was told that the baby was going to be
have such and such defect
and it their their their proposed
abortion when well no we're we're going
to see how this turns out and then it
turns out that there aren't defects
there isn't Down syndrome or
whatever there there's a certain
mistrust of is there this zero
population growth agenda maam you're
you're at your three minute point so I'd
ask you to finish up uh yes I just want
you to recognize that we're deciding on
your deciding on life and death here and
I'll leave it at that thank you thank
you Katherine Tucker and on Deck will be
a d
David
L David H L laru okay thank you all
right
oh got okay all right hi good afternoon
uh members of the committee my name is
Katherine Tucker I am from lonia I am an
attorney and I practice fertility law so
I work with lots of folks who are trying
to get pregnant or who are pregnant I'm
here on behalf of all paths family
building a nonprofit that supports
people who are trying to build their
families so I work with people who want
to be pregnant who desperately want to
have a baby this bill is bad for them
there are complications that can happen
during the pregnancy that are going to
hurt these women and hurt and and just
cause tremendous pain you've heard about
that from the doctors the things that
happen after 15 weeks impact very much
wanted pregnancies and we want our
doctors to be able to treat those women
and to provide them with Compassionate
Care at a very difficult time of very
much wanted pregnancy and I'll I'll I'll
just address that question about the the
fetal Anatomy coming from a lawyer's P
perspective we work with surrogates and
when we have a surrogate we will have
make sure that surrogate is having an
anatomy scan around 20 weeks of
pregnancy we would love to do it earlier
if we could do that at 10 weeks or 12
weeks we absolutely would do that
everybody wants answers to know how that
fetus is forming but we can't do it
until later on because the the vital
organs are not formed until later on so
20 weeks is where we can start really
looking look at the heart the kidneys
all of those things that that we need to
look at and these are very much wanted
pregnancies this bill would be very bad
for these pregnancies and it's just not
right for New Hampshire thank you very
much ma'am uh David L if you have
written testimony can you ma'am do you
have we subm online oh you submit it
online great thank you David laroo and
on Deck will be
Ryan
McKennon m
my name is David laru I'm the father of
two sons under three years old uh a
little under seven weeks ago I just
caught my second son in my own hands in
my own home with my wife and I and I can
tell you coming through the birth canal
does not change whether that is a life
or not okay I don't know whether I
actually support this bill or not
because I really do not hear
conversation about the true issues here
okay we are not speaking about the due
process of law that is supposed to be
afforded to life if you Google life AI
Google says life is defined by a set of
characteristics that distinguish living
organizations from non-living matter
including the ability to reproduce grow
metabolize respond to stimuli maintain
the homeostasis adapt to their
environment and exhibit organized
cellular structures essentially a
self-sustaining system capable of
undergoing Evolution I would challenge
you to run that definition through the
idea if you were in a car accident and
you are now on life support or in a coma
or you are born with Down Syndrome or
you have some other anomaly or some
action that happens to you in life are
you no now are you no longer now
subjected to the protections of Life do
we have a right to life we have a right
to not be deprived of our life until we
have had due process whether that is
while we are alive or post humously in
the case of a wrongful homicide explain
to me how we can give due process of law
to that clearly defin Defined
Life when it is still in the womb as I
understand it New Hampshire still on the
books has a fetal homicide law that in
March of this last year somebody was was
indicted for a double homicide for
killing a woman and 37 week old baby as
I read that law as I understand it's
still in the books that is a 20 we
standard that the state says after 20
weeks this is considered personhood for
the purposes of Criminal
Intent at between 20 and 24 weeks I
cannot kill the baby without fear of
homicide but a mother or a For Hire
practitioner can legally medicine is not
a right in this country I'm old enough
to remember Co where it was demanded you
follow the government instructed um
rights and most medical organized people
were demanding you bow down to
government pressure okay a baby has its
own independent DNA from
conception if you had your DNA or there
was another set of DNA at a crime you
would demand that that was not your
obligation to pay for that because it is
not your DNA okay the right to not be
deprived of your life this is what is
essential it is not a feel-good measure
it is not a right to medicine if that
was logically true and legally true we
must bring in all manner of surgeries
and expensive cares into the domain of
your rights that you must be forced to
take
the fruit of somebody else's labor and
their
occupation because it is your right I'm
sorry sir you know you've reached your
three minute Mark so I'd ask you to
please finish up to sum it up medicine
in this country is almost $5
billion it is over 17% of our gross
domestic
product the right to life is a gross
misrepresentation of what we actually
have under the law but clearly this is
life and that is the issue that needs to
be decided within the courts before you
place arbitrary deadlines on these
things thank you thank you very much all
right Ryan McKennon and on Deck will be
Brian
uh Richards Richardson yes all
right hi my name is Ryan McKenna I'm an
attorney and a native to this state um
this I I am here to urge support for
House Bill 476 in uh opposition to the
amendment uh this is clearly a touchy
subject while I was here my wife texted
me that there was a 3.9 magnitude
earthquake which uh I'm sure happened by
chance but regardless this is a touchy
subject and I come here to make two
points and a practical
observation um my first point is that I
think this issue is right for debate and
um and the and the subject is when when
is the deadline up to which you can have
an abortion right I think that issue is
right for debate based on the Overton
window I think the second uh point I
wanted to make is is really to ask the
question whose job is it to have this
debate and in the opinion of this
speaker it's it's your job and I'd urge
you to have that debate and then my
practical observation is just as a
father who uh recently lost a baby at 10
weeks through miscarriage um and have
seven children I'm somewhat familiar
with the with the physical aspects of it
as well as um the effect on the on the
men right on the father um but what what
it made me realize is there's a custom n
really around the world when do you
announce that you're pregnant how many
weeks should you be before you make that
announcement and there's clearly a
higher risk of miscarriage before you
know 10 weeks uh and I think the custom
was always 12 weeks you wait waited 12
weeks to make the pregnancy public to
your friends and family so I think that
I just wanted to come here and make that
practical observation as to there's a
time when this sort of um Private Matter
becomes public and the custom is 12
weeks we we chose to announce a little
bit premature I'd say 10 weeks and that
happened so here the medical providers
in the room provided many examples of
exceptions that imply in my opinion
logical asent to the general rule that
an adequate medical reason or other
reason is needed and often exists for
terminating a pregnancy I've not heard
of medical provider make the case for
opposition using example of a healthy
mother and a healthy 16we child in utero
I think you have a responsibility to
balance the state's obligation to
preserve Life In Utero with the mother's
interests for for health and safety and
this is the debate in in my opinion it's
your job to have that issue is whether
15 weeks is the appropriate Mark um
Cornerstone action published a survey
that showed that 60 to 65% of New
Hampshire constituents support an
abortion ban after 15 weeks with
exceptions that should be debated and
that um this bill enables debate on a on
a topic that's been suppressed for for
over 50 years and biased I think over
that time C culturally um I have nothing
further to add other than that I call
upon you especially New Hampshire
Republicans as as a republican who uh as
a as a registered Republican to not
abnegate the duties you took an oath to
uphold please debate this bill on the
floor and I urge you to support it thank
you thank you very much sir all right um
next is Brian Richardson and on Deck
will be Kathy
stratt thank you host J Judiciary
Committee for allowing me to speak to
this bill this
morning
um I uh didn't know until I I got here
that the uh the bill had been uh
somewhat changed um so um but we uh many
of us still stayed
anyways I want to say uh in that I hope
that you all agree with me that you wish
uh representative former representative
David testerman well um he uh we we know
that he's that he's he's been sick and
uh we we remember him here and we we
miss
him um my wife I'm here on behal of
myself my family I am a a father
grandfather uh a
great-grandfather um I'm here on behalf
of my my wife who is a who works who
does ultrasounds for a Pregnancy Care
Center she's sick today she's was not
able to be here we we uh do thank you
all for your support of the great work
that the Pregnancy Care Centers
do um and I'm here on behalf of my
grandson who is uh who I am actually the
caretaker of who is 23 years old who uh
was born with Down Syndrome it's
wonderful wonderful young man and uh we
we love him to death we
uh we know that we know that through the
Pregnancy Care Center that um that we
can detect life well before 24
months and we know that there is
selective proced procedures done for
people who are known to have Down
syndrome which is really sad because
they're wonderful
people I want to I want to ask and I'm
not going to belabor you too much
further but I want to ask that you
support this
bill and any bill in the future that
agrees with the people of this of this
state that majority of the people
believe that abortion should not be
done
before or after 16 weeks 15 weeks and I
ask that you support the bill and uh I
ask that you do not support the
amendment thank you thank you very much
sir uh next is Kathy Stratton and on
Deck is representative
Mary H Hank and Phillips
good afternoon you guys have been here a
long time um I'll try to keep it brief I
have written testimony and I will submit
it
electronically um dear chairman Lynn
members of this committee my name is
Kathy Stratton and I'm the CEO of the
New Hampshire Medical Society I'm also a
mother to three wonderful humans I'm
speaking on behalf of the medical
society today in opposition of House
Bill 476 the legislation seeking to
restrict reproductive care in New
Hampshire the New Hampshire Medical
Society strongly opposes governmental
inter interference in the doctor patient
relationship and laws that restrict a
patient's right to access evidence-based
Health Care as you've heard from the
many Physicians clinicians and parents
providing testimony today elective
abortions are medical care care that
takes into consideration the physical
and mental health of the patient
as well as other complex
circumstances the Physicians on my board
of directors on the council that governs
the advocacy of the medical society and
the members of my Association have
countless years of experience practicing
medicine and taking care of New
Hampshire's citizens and families these
doctors took an oath to First Do no harm
and as you know unplanned pregnancy
happens sometimes in spite of the use of
appropriate contraception and proper
precautions some of their patients have
been raped trafficked and vict and are
victims of incest some patients will
have no medical complications of
pregnancy until much later in their term
under this law there is no pres
provision for a 13-year-old child who
would be required to deliver a baby
resulting in unimaginable trauma and
additional loss of bodily autonomy and
victimization there's no Pro provision
for the victim of rape or the mother of
two who faces considerable medical risk
in carrying an additional
child this law would deny patients the
bodily autonomy they deserve and the
opportunity to proceed with medical care
that is safe and performed within a
trusted medical
relationship the medical society opposes
legislation that penalizes and
criminalizes evidence-based practices it
is imperative that New Hampshire laws
continue to support clinical
relationships between a physician and
their patient and the full spectrum of
Health Care within a well-informed
clinical setting I would like to leave
you with a few thought-provoking points
medical decisions as we've heard today
are personal like all medical matters
decisions regarding abortion should be
made only by patients in consultation
with their physician and Health Care
Professionals regulating scientifically
and evidence-based Medical Care is a
slippery slope to all of us
the decision to treat heart dis me ma'am
your your time is up I'd ask you if you
just please sum sum it up okay in
conclusion the medical society believes
that well-informed evidence-based
practices should not be tampered with
should not tamper with a physician and
clinician and their patients that they
serve the medical society opposes the
criminalization of any medically
necessary treatment thank you very much
thank you for your time all right
representative Mary haen Phillips and on
deck will be
uh
uh Mark
mey Lether
Lear anyway representative aen
Phillips thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee my name is Mary hackin
Phillips I'm the representative from
Grafton 12 representing Handover and
lime I'm so honored be to be with you
today but I'm here in Opp position for
HB
476 I believe this bill is harmful to
patients providers the entire Healthcare
System and our economy but more
importantly I think it's politically
impracticable let's just say that we
decide to ignore the governor's
statements or our own caucuses our the
sponsors in this case and maybe your own
campaign
assurances let's say you ignore the
science the polling the economics the
testimon of experts and the really
passionate thoughtful testimony from
everyday Granite Staters and even some
religious leaders let's say you ignore
the fact that a cruel 15we abortion ban
with vague language will effectively be
signing death warrants for people like
your family members who might experience
complications in pregnancy and run out
of time or could not afford to travel to
other states for healthcare access let's
just say you ignore all the science the
facts the logic the reason the humanity
and you go ahead and you pass this bill
let's be clear passage of HB
476 will accelerate the quickening pace
of voting age electorate members in New
Hampshire that run not walk away from
the party that passes the law and
towards candidates who will protect
independent medical decision-making and
the right to reproductive healthc care
Choice let this be a warning a 15we
abortion ban will trigger a gener a
generational wave against entrusting
those who pass it to craft public policy
the party responsible will be unlikely
to fully recover passage of HB 476 will
be a strategic failure and a colossal
mistake I'm here finally on behalf of my
provider constituents and the maternally
reproductive age individuals of my
district and myself to express my deep
disappointment that we even need to
expend
this much Collective energy and these
resources to entertain a bill that
further restricts reproductive health
care for women without acknowledging and
without naming the true discrimination
that pregnant individuals in New
Hampshire are facing due to ongoing
political attacks the mere fact that
we're not discussing the efficacy or
wisdom of restricting male reproductive
Health Care procedures when a man is 50%
of all causes for pregnancies
demonstrates the true discrimination
against and Injustice thrust upon women
and pregnant people here in New
Hampshire this is the point that really
gets me upset a tax on access to women's
health care but not to Men's Health Care
is blatant discrimination based on sex
and it's a substantial government
interference into privacy and medical
privacy but even though I'm angry about
these attacks and for my constituents
providers patients and myself I'm
dedicated to defeating bills like this
HB 476
to ensure access to safe and effective
reproductive healthare procedures your
time and for these reasons I urge
bipartisan defeat of HB 476 please vote
no if you have the opportunity today um
and or inexpedient to legislate if you
see fit thank you thank you very much um
I I think maybe it's Haley
Haley lethar
Lear uh it's uh doesn't say a town ask
for one minute time
Haley the um the address I'm I'm just
going to say the first the number of the
address is 48 48 and I'm not going to
say the street name but that ringing a
bell to
anybody right next moving on all right
moving on next will be yeah Maggie uh
Burnham
and on Deck will be Leia
eastley Maggie
Burnham Maggie Burnham apparently not
here all right Leia
Easley oh she already tested okay so
she's one of them all right um Abigail
Robbins please and next will be
Katherine Evans
you know what I think you're you you
turned the yeah that's it thank you I'm
actually very disappointed that we're
still here talking about this this is
something that has it should have ended
52 years ago with roie Wade and the fact
that I am here I'm a student I should be
studying right now not here defending my
rights and trying to make sure that the
little girls that I took took care of I
was a nanny for
years and I have to look at them and
watch them grow with less rights than I
did when I was born to do this to put
this bill through robs them of the
rights that I should have that they
should have to their own bodies to their
own bodily autonomies to say yes to
continue to push women back down
it puts us back into a time where I I
don't even remember cuz I wasn't born
yet this is 52 years that you will be
sending us back
to 15 minutes I mean 15 weeks is not
enough time to be able to make a
decision like this this is a
life-changing
decision and it affects so many pregnant
women I've had reconsider whether or not
I'm going to have children because of
bills like this because I don't know if
I can trust that you have our best
decisions in mind when I see these
things especially at the very beginning
of the year this is January and we're
already discussing a ban on abortions
again this is the beginning of the year
and this is where we're taking our first
steps we're not
acknowledging the actual problems that
are going on in this state right now
there is a major housing issue where I
probably won't be able to afford a home
until I'm well into my 40s and even then
I probably still won't be able to afford
one I'm so disappointed that I am here
today that I had to drive over over an
hour to get here and wait for
hours listening to all these
heartbreaking
stories and to worry that it's falling
on De
ears that is my fear right
now that people are not being
heard because if we were we wouldn't be
here right
now I'm so disappointed and I'm so ma'am
you're you're at your three minute mark
thank you thank you very much Catherine
Evans and on Deck is Amanda uh
Sienna hi hi I'm Katherine Evans I'm
from nsha and um I'm here to um oppose
the bill um I want to take just a moment
to to invite everyone to think about the
word choice I have been thinking about
that a lot ever since I came into this
room I want to thank everyone who's here
I want to thank everyone who came who um
drove a long time uh maybe came last
minute because they were nervous like me
I was kind of scared to come I just
never did something like this before um
and I was you know not planning on
talking but here I am and those are all
choices you know simple choices but some
of us have really hard
choices um I have two children uh 13 and
11 they're wonderful and I'm so grateful
I have great health insurance and it's a
good thing I do because my son needs a
lot of support uh for uh he's um
autistic and um lots of therapies um
there are women who do not have such um
or um as fortunate as I am um I am
fortunate that I did not have to make a
choice to keep or terminate a child a
pregnancy um but I'm glad that I had the
choice I never thought that I wouldn't
and I'm worried about my 11-year-old
daughter um you know I can't help but
think am I supposed you know will we
have to talk about you know birth
control at a young age because says who
knows what could happen I have never
been raped I am so fortunate in all of
those senses but there are women who are
not as fortunate my heart goes out to um
the women who shared their experiences
of losing a pregnancy that was truly
wanted that's devastating and my heart
goes out to them um one more thing I
want to say about Choice when people are
able to adopt a child they're able to
choose they're able to
choose the child that they're going to
adopt if someone's going to use a
surrogate they get to choose who's going
to carry their baby if a person has like
a long history of mental illness in
their family like me or is on
anti-depressants and anxiety medicine
like me and they want to be a surrogate
chances are they're not going to be
chosen so please allow women to have a
choice um factchecking I I did look at
France to see what their abortion laws
were um and I just want to share real
quick you know um yes uh upon request
until 14 weeks um after conception 16
weeks after the woman's last paragade
I'm shaking I'm sorry abortion at a
later state in pregnancy up until birth
are allowed if two Physicians certify
that the abortion you're you're at your
uh thre minute Mark ma'am so just ask
you to please finish up quickly oh
absolutely it will be done to prevent
injury to the physical and mental health
of the pregnant woman risk of life um of
the pregnant woman or that the child
will suffer from a particular severe
illness uh recognized as
incurable thank you very much thank you
everybody right Amanda Sienna and on
Deck is
[Music]
Michael
sism it's sh sorry
um so my name is Amanda shenna I'm 46
years old I've got a couple kids um I'm
here from California I live in exitor
now um I've had one ectopic one
miscarriage and one abortion and two
live births um at 17 I discovered I was
pregnant at 21 weeks despite uh what
others may have said I had no uh visible
symptoms I continued to have my period I
was unaware of my pregnancy I gave birth
to my son after becoming pregnant by an
abuse Ive partner two weeks following my
delivery I developed a severe infection
from retained tissue in my
uterus I had a high fever excruciating
pain and couldn't walk without a DNC
which is a dilation and cage um and
antibiotics I would have gone into
septic shock and this procedure saved my
life I want to emphasize that
reproductive healthc care is complex
there are countless pieces to this
deeply personal puzzle medical history
personal circumstances physical health
mental well-being safety and
survival no single law can capture the
intricate Realties women face when
making reproductive decisions and
domestic violence has also shaped my
story um and the DNC procedure itself um
is often misrepresented as being solely
used for abortions but it's critical for
treating complications after childbirth
miscarriages and even diagnosing
conditions that I have like endomet
iosis unfortunately restrictive laws in
some states have created confusion and
fear among Health Care Providers when
performing
dncs for pregnancy related complications
like incomplete
miscarriages or
infections I also had an ectopic
pregnancy at the age of
28 um I faced it's obviously a
life-threatening situation um and again
they use the DNC to see if there was any
fetal tissue in my uterus which there
wasn't than they did a
laparoscopy
um so these experiences underscore the
importance of accessible reproductive
Health
Care
um restrictive laws like House Bill 476
could delay or deny life-saving care to
women facing medical emergencies like
mine and like Porsche and other women in
Missouri um um please oppose this bill
to ensure women continue to have access
to the critical nuanced care that they
need to survive and enclosing
reproductive health care is about
survival not
politics these procedures Sav lives they
saved mine every restriction puts women
at risk protect our right to critical
Medical Care and oppose House Bill 476
thank you thank you very much ma'am uh
Michaels I hope I'm pronouncing this
right schism
from West
Sanbornton West
Sanbornton right not seeing him here I
guess put that aside Uh Kevin costum
right and on deck and I believe our
last witness oh no I'm sorry on Deck
will be uh
Patricia gadzik hi there um I'm Kevin
costan I'm a native of New Hampshire and
um just a concerned citizen I showed up
today not prepared to speak or anything
like that but I just wanted to make a
few observations that I don't see many
medal medical practitioners in favor of
this bill was there any um I think that
we should be more trusting to science
than denying it and I heard some murmur
outside saying that you know these
medical practitioners are for-profit and
that's all they care about and I think
that's pretty
despicable um with that said just short
and sweet uh If you deny science you're
denying life because life is science
thank you very much sir Patricia Gad
gadz I think and then I the last witness
is uh Chris Christine
Peters hi I'm Patricia godzik um I am a
hookit resident and a small business
owner here in um New Hampshire I'm also
a um Survivor of not only domestic
violence from the time of I was very
young
but also a survivor of um essay and um a
foster mom who recently adopted
her adoptive son who I love to death um
so it's really easy to say that adoption
is the answer to this but unless you are
going through the adoption process you
don't know
that um recently I want to tell you a
story and I'm hoping that you're all
listening I have PCOS and I've been
diagnosed with PCOS at a young age so I
was infertile for many many years um
after eight years of trying to have a a
child we gave up and decided to go
through the TR the foster care system um
only to magically conceive and not
remember
conceiving
um
2022 New Year's Eve I found out about my
daughter Amelia and and I was absolutely
in love and didn't tell anybody until we
were 13 weeks along we didn't find out
until we were 8 weeks
along when this all happened we were so
blessed but if you remember in 2022
everyone was talking about the 24-week
abortion man the 24-week abortion man I
looked at my husband and I said who
wouldn't know at 24 weeks whether they
want to keep a child or not and we
laughed about it
until my 16
week uh doctor's appointment and I felt
something wrong and I asked for an
ultrasound and they said sorry we don't
do that you're going to have to wait
until your 20we
checkup they let me hear her heartbeat
and everything was fine everything was
normal because of covid we couldn't hear
my daughter's heart we could only hear
my daughter's heartbeat we didn't get to
get in until 2020 22 weeks at 22 weeks
we found out she was only measuring at
15 weeks and that she had a genetic
abnormality that made her not compatible
with Life she had a heartbeat bands like
this 15 week band started in States like
Texas that now have heartbeat
bands in my condition I in Texas we
would not have been able to go through
with the
termination because she had a heartbeat
but you know what you need to have lungs
to be able to survive survive you need
to be able to have kidneys to be able to
survive and I was in hysterics I called
my doctor every single day and I said
are you sure are you sure I don't know
what to do and because of the 24 week
band I had 4 days to make a
decision four days and as I'm holding my
daughter in my belly I had four days to
make a decision ma'am I'm sorry you're
uh you're really over the line ask you
to finish up your testimony to make a
decision whether it she could be here or
not so I just ask that when you guys are
passing this bill or disapproving this
bill while that's going across your desk
that you think of my daughter Amelia
hope godzik thank you thank you very
much uh Christine Peters
please Christine
Peters members of the Judiciary
Committee that my name is Christine
Peters and I want to thank you for going
ahead with today's hearing even though I
understand it's not likely this bill is
going to go forward um in its original
capacity at least um I came here today
initially to ask you to let the bill go
to the floor and let those in the house
who wanted to go on record um in favor
of protecting babies who are paying
capable from having their lives ended
apart from some of the exceptions that
are laid out in the bill as I've sat
here this morning my heart goes out to
many women I too have experienced
pregnancy complications I have um held
the hands of women who have uh been
notified their babies were not
compatible with life and and I I think
we all understand that when the life of
the mother is in danger when the
certainty of fetal demise has been
confirmed those are not situations we're
talking about what we are talking about
is the value of two lives and uh again I
would like to have seen this be able to
go forward so that the rest of your
colleagues could have the same
conversation uh on the house floor um
and I I just stand here in support of
this bill and thank you all for your
time and for continuing today thank you
all right um I don't have any other pink
cars is there anyone else who wishes to
be heard on uh House Bill 476 that is
the main bill
the no no no I we're talking about the
main bill right now so I don't see
anyone else here on the main bill um and
uh so I'm going to close the hearing on
the main Bill and I'm going to uh sort
of immediately open the hearing on the
nonre main Amendment and since I'm the
sponsor of it I'm going to take just a
few minutes to testify and I'll turn the
proceeding over to my colleague but I
quit representative uh
o sorry about
that just give me
a Katie I think I have order for you
I think
I
oh yeah unless I don't have any problem
with I just want to make sure that the
it doesn't interfere with hearing all
right
we're just doing some housekeeping here
first no fine no problem
okay we're going to open the hearing on
the amendment to House Bill 476 I don't
even know if it has a number if it's
been assigned a number yet we we do it's
um thank you Mr chair my my name is uh
Representative Bob Lynn I'm from
Rockingham District 17 the town of
Windam and the amendment number is 2 20
25-31 and I realized just now that I
have not filled out a pin card but I
will do that before I come back to uh
the table um so I'm uh I uh offer this
amendment this uh is an amendment uh a
non gerain Amendment to the bill it
establishes a reporting requirement for
reporting on um abortion abortions that
are conduct that are conducted um and it
requires the Department of Health and
Human Services basically to provide that
information um on an annual basis um uh
to to provide reports it contains
Provisions for confidentiality now I I
from discussions I've had uh with
Planned Parenthood over the weekend I
understand that they have
concerns about
the terms of this bill in terms of
whether it provides sufficient
protection for for um uh
confidentiality um I'm going to be
interested to hear what they have to say
I it it seemed to me as I looked at this
that that it did have sufficient uh
protections but you know obviously I and
and I think all of us would stand to be
educated if if I'm wrong on that I
should say so that everyone knows this
bill is Tak literally word for word from
a
2016 bill I believe it was
2016 House Bill 629 I think I've got
that number right um it's taken
literally from that and the only changes
that I made to that bill um was did
obviously change the dates of
Effectiveness and things like that and
to add a provision in
uh in on which is on page two it begins
at uh line 16 it it it's the the
sentence there that that uh States a
healthc care provider or Facility Who
knowingly or recklessly fails to report
the induced termination of a pregnancy
under this section shall be guilty of a
violation and shall be fined an amount
not to exceed $11,000 for each offense
that's other than the date changes uh
that's the only change that I made to
that 2016 house bill um other than that
um that's that's all I have to say well
I'm sorry I should say one other thing
my understanding is and again from this
is from discussions with various people
that there
isn't much in the way of opposition to
the idea that there should be a
reporting requirement um I as I
understand from my discussions with par
Planned Parenthood they are on board
with with uh with the idea of a
reporting requirement it's just the the
details of what the confidentiality
restrictions should be that that are the
matter an issue I would note that as in
the brief research I did with Mr Google
it appears that um there are only four
states that don't have some kind of
reporting requirement California
Maryland New Jersey and New Hampshire
um so it's you know it doesn't sound
like this is a um red state blue State
kind of thing um other than that um
that's all I have to say and to the
extent I know the answers to any of the
questions you may have I'm happy to try
to answer them any questions
yes um thank you representative Lynn um
I'm a substitute on the committee today
so um what what is the purpose of of the
bill why do we need reporting I guess is
what I'm trying to get at well you know
I think that's a really good question
and you know I should I I if I suspect
you probably know this but um I'm
someone who is not I am not going to
vote for the underlying bill I mean I
basically consider myself to be a
pro-choice person I favored the 24 week
band because I do think that even for a
pro-choice person like me at some point
it just gets to be too late and I think
24 weeks is a reasonable thing but
having said that I do support a
reporting bill because I think you know
I think it's important to have accurate
information on what um on how many
abortions are being performed and you
know I I've said this before maybe last
year in committee I think that um in
some sense both sides of this issue um
there there's some
sentiment to uh to want to not to want
to not do this in new I'm not quite sure
why in New Hampshire but there seems to
be and I can't help thinking that both
sides are afraid of what the result
might be because if the result shows as
I suspect it will that there are very
few late term abortions for example then
you know one side is going to say well
look why do we need these what do we
need a 24 restriction week restriction
for there aren't really very many if any
abortions after 24 weeks anyway and most
of them would be allowed because there's
some kind of you know exceptional
circumstance so what do we need to have
a 24-week ban for and the other side
would say wait a minute there aren't
very many 24 week there aren't very many
abortions after 24 weeks so what's the
harm why don't you know maybe there are
some that are really you know it's just
outrageous so what's the harm of having
the 24-week ban and my sense is let's
get the information and then I don't
know who will win that argument if there
if that is the kind of argument that's
made but let's at least have the
information so that's why I support
it representative
Smith thank you very much um I have a
problem and I guess I need
advice left to my own devices and always
wanting to hear from the public I would
not ask you any questions now but wait
for other people to come before us and
help
elaborate either support or opposition
to the amendment with the possibility
that we might ask for you to to be
willing to sit in that chair
again um but I I'm now
confounded about what to do
because you've made some statements that
are very interesting but I don't think
address the real focus of this amendment
for example I have always
supported and it's this is a question
but no it is a question I'm trying to
figure out how to ask it um that see
that that's that's usually usually you
can end by saying isn't that true or
something like that yeah but you know
that's disingenuous and that's not the
way I really like to proceed
um I I guess what I'd like to say Mr
chairman is at this point I would like
to see the um the hearing unfold and
with the understanding that if it would
be appropriate we might want to ask the
prime sponsor to come and sit before us
again so that we could ask questions
after that with that be acceptable I
think we could do that all right all
right representative
sure thank you I I'm also a substitute
um nice to be
here um I'm just trying to put this in a
in a broader context um uh I uh you know
we just listened to you know close to
four hours of of of uh testimony about
the underlying bill which uh I
understand the the depth of uh feeling
on both sides uh and as I see this bill
um it is uh it doesn't have that uh
depth of uh controversy and feeling is
that fair thing to say on the reporting
yes I think on the reporting I think
that's true I mean I you know I have we
have other Witnesses who may may prove
me wrong but followup followup um
so I'm just again putting this in
context so as I see it this is gathering
this data is useful but fair to say it's
not necessary
well I you know I guess I would I don't
think I I mean it depends I suppose on
what you mean by necessary but 46 other
states have thought that it was
necessary so I tend to think for the
reasons I've said before um and maybe
for other you know other sort of Health
Care kind of reasons it might be
necessary I I think it probably I think
I wouldn't wouldn't agree with you on
that okay fair to say we could both
agree that it certainly would be helpful
is that a Fair that's that's all right I
I I agree with that okay thank you any
other questions seeing none thank you
thank
you the chair will'll call is it
Courtney Tanner from dmouth
El hi there Courtney Tanner for the
record I'm the senior director of
government relations at Dart moual and
we are my understanding you heard from a
number of our care providers this
morning we uh proud we're an entity that
is proud of providing reproductive
Health Care to women across the Spectrum
um we have Services uh for pregnant and
parent parenting women um all the way to
providing abortion Services uh to women
who need and want to access those those
services and uh we are proud to be the
home of specialized uh um obstetric
services for women who are in need of
abortions at a later
term we believe that access to Quality
protected Health that
does Ensure Better Health outcomes and
uh it's in these rooms where we're
always working to balance um protected
health information for our patients the
safety of our providers and ensuring
that we as a state have access to
Quality comprehensive data um to drive
better health outcomes and so when I
think about that I know you don't have
to think about vaccine Registries or
cancer Registries in this committee but
we do in other committees and so um I
want to make sure that as we as I
testify on this amendment that I'm
underscoring it's really important for
us that we're balancing the right of
privacy and uh collection of of health
information representative Lynn is
correct there are 46 other states that
do collect this information um and this
concept is not new as representative
Lynn pointed out this was contemplated
in 2016 but it's also being contemplated
in the Senate there's a bill Senate Bill
36 uh that we just testified on last
week and um I believe the Senate is
going to be doing some work on that bill
we do have some concerns about this
amendment and I and I have to oppose
this amendment but I'm committed to
working on Senate Bill 33 with the
Senate and hopefully with this committee
as it as it crosses over um as it
crosses over here one thing that is
really important for the record we in
New Hampshire have a really low volume
of later um term abortions here in New
Hampshire and so any data into a
registry or um a collection entity like
this
it we're going to have to be really sure
that we're buttoning up privacy
protections because of that low volume
it's going to be very easy to identify
patients and providers if that is not
done in a protected um thoughtful way
I'm happy to take questions
um but that's that's our testimony thank
you uh representative
maner thank you um does this bill comply
with
HIPPA so um it looks to be that this
amendment
um I have concerns about uh Hippa
because this amendment would require the
the collection of abortion statistics to
a non-hp covered entity this collection
entity would be um through our security
uh Secretary of State and so um our
secretary of state is not a hip cover
entity and for that reason we would be
concerned about
privacy are you specific are you
specifically concerned that it does not
comply with HIPPA yes
any other
questions yes representative mcfar
further to that last
question I I want to take this in two
parts you spoke to concerns around the
anonymity of the data and I'll come back
to that sure I if you
accept uh arguendo that the an anonymity
achieved by saying over 20,000 is
sufficient then could you explain what
it is in the nature of the data that
would be submitted to the Secretary of
State's office uh that would in fact
constitute Phi under
Hippa um well over there are not over
20,000 abortions uh after the after 18
weeks that are being provided in the
state of New Hampshire in fact there's
fewer than a 100 from our entity alone I
think your misunderstanding I'm
referring to the the part of the
amendment where it talks about
anonymizing data uh at least to the
level of and let me find the actual
reference here um if the population of
the municipality exceeds 20,000 you know
but again let's come back to the
question around how it's anonymized and
and first of all address as written in
this amendment the data that would be
submitted to the Secretary of State's
office what is in the nature of that
data that you think is covered under
Hippa so there I so my testimony is that
there that the Secretary of State's
office Vital Records is not a hpoc
covered entity I I heard that so this
would not be protected health
information and I would have concerns
about this amendment um flying in the
face of of Hippo as in totality would
you agree that if I sent a newspaper
article containing information about how
many abortions there had been in New
Hampshire to the Secretary of State's
office that the secretary of state would
still not be a hip covered entity and
that that would be frankly irrelevant so
uh you know would you agree to
that uh I'm not sure I I I'm not sure
I'm happy to explore that with you but
I'm not sure how to answer that right
now okay is there any further testimony
that you could provide that would help
us understand more about the nature of
your specific concerns with regard to
Hippa I am happy to work on the concept
of of an abortion collection process
here in New Hampshire I just don't think
this bill the vehicle thank you any
other
questions seeing none thank
you Caleb
Montgomery we can do
that Abby Rogers
good morning my name is Abby Rogers I'm
the legisla blaz on for the division of
Public Health
Services for the record my name is joa
cha I'm the bureau chief of Public
Health static informatic in the division
of Public Health
Services thank you um so we wanted to
come to to speak about the amendment
today um we have some serious concerns
around certain elements of amendment
25318 uh one of the top priorities of
the Department of Health and Human
Services is the health of mothers and
babies with the objective to promote
strategies and to support healthy
pregnancies Early Childhood uh reduce
unintended pregnancies especially among
adolescents um I'll let you
continue so the amendment number 2500
31h would require the division of Vital
Records Administration under the
Secretary of State to collect a
non-identifying confidential data um
induct uh indued the termination of
pregnancy using the New Hampshire V
records information Network never
systems so the proposed uh Amendment
states that the termination of pregnancy
statistic data will be released from Nan
to the department DHHS uh to to analyze
and compile um an annual report the
report will contain and aggregate
statistical summary of all induced
determination of pregnancy performed in
New Hampshire and will be available to
the public starting on November 1st
2026 the proposed legislation requires
the department uh DHHS to assign a
confidential number to each health care
provider and medical facility that are
required to submit the induced
determination of pregnancy data on a
department uh created electronic forms
so the amendment uh unfortunately does
not uh contemplate contemplate the
needed appropriation to support data
collection review validation preparation
and posting um of this
report the department has concerns with
the amendment
requirements for certain data elements
uh protection of privacy and alignment
with the current statue in addition uh
the department is a hippoc covered
entity so the department is concerned
with the lack of clarity around Hippa
protection in the amendment languages in
order to protect the privacy of the
protected health information collected
there is a need to reference to Hippa
law in including definition of
reproductive Health um prohibited
purposes and requirements for an
attestation for disc colure or use of
the um protective health information
potentially related to productive health
and currently there are specific statute
uh that governs how V record statistic
data is shared between the division of V
record Administration under the
Secretary of State and the department
DHHS if this bill moves forward this may
require the statute Chang to include uh
the induced determination of pregancy
data information and how it will be
shared with the
Department it is also unclear how this
legislation will align with the Federal
Life protection act reporting
requirement which is under the statute
RSA
329 um column 45 uh which we have
included in our written Tes
monies so while no fiscal impact note
was requested the department estimate an
uh an approximately of
$150,000 in staff resources plus $10,000
for training in the fiscal year 26 for
data collection review validation and
Reporting and please note that this
estimate does not include the resources
needed for the division of vle Records
under the Secretary of State to create
uh the required modules in their never
system the department understands its
responsibility in protecting privacy and
securing this information which is why
ex streeming care must be taken in
defining potential data elements and
ensuring that adequate resources are
available to support support uh the
development of necessary systems and
ongoing operations because of the
technical requirements and financial
considerations it is unlikely the data
will be securely reported and collected
by January
2026 and I'll hand it over to
as thank you chawe um the over the past
decade the general court has considered
several ways as representative Lynn has
mentioned previous bills uh dating back
from 20 I think you said 2016 maybe um
we also found um in our history um
various abortion uh statistic bills back
in 2022 as well um and the general court
has has considered several ways in which
to collect abortion statistics but
currently um the department has not been
has not been given authority to do so um
currently as um one of our previous
speakers mentioned um there is Senate
Bel 36 which the department did testify
on last week as well as some other folks
um in the Senate health and human Human
Services committee
uh that bill is proposing a method which
may have fewer technical concerns than
what has been being proposed in this
amendment I know that there were um uh
it is being worked on um regardless of
the method um the cost of Hipp hippoc
compliant data collection and Analysis
must be considered there are currently
no funds budgeted for this purpose now
or contemplated in future budgets and
the fiscal note that the department had
worked on um for that other bill would
um have been um quite expensive over 900
uh $900,000 for a HIPPA secure uh
database and as well as some staff
positions so um we're happy to take any
questions um on Upon Our
concerns thank you any questions yes
representative uh McFarland thank you so
thank you for your testimony um further
to the the testimony we've heard from
you and from the last individual I'd
just like to understand would you agree
that under Hippa information that is
deidentified uh as defined by removing
direct and indirect identifiers is not
considered Phi and therefore would be
outside of the scope of
HIPPA thank you for the question first
of all I'm not really a hip-hop privacy
officer per se but whatever we release
related to health risk we also take into
account on the suppression rules so to
suppress like little numbers that even
even in the state level uh to avoid this
kind like identifications so um for the
general um reporting we do report for
example um asthma rate uh in the state
of New Hampshire applying the separation
rule in it and for this kind of
reporting it will not be um revealed the
Phi and that's what we are allowed to
report so forgive me if I misunderstood
your testimony I I was under the
impression from what you were saying
that the the thrust of your argument is
that this amendment would contravene
hipper but you're saying you're not a
hipper expert is that right sorry again
thank you for your question so we are
talking about two parts to collect the
data that would be under our Hippa um
whether we have the authority legal
authority to collect this kind of a data
in to us to report the data we also need
to follow the Hippa and then to report
the Hippa if it's aggregated level with
implementation and also Safeguard
methods implemented then we will be able
to release the data that without U
violating the Hippa so those are the two
um um two two two things two component
that we we are talking about in this
amendment thank you thank you
representative Sher thank you um
fair to say dhss has been uh engaging in
strategies I'm looking at uh the letter
to support healthy pregnancy and early
childhood and reduce unintended
pregnancies particularly among
adolescent before the existence of this
bill better to
say uh you actually have to say a word
rather than just not that's correct um
and this bill would improve that uh dhss
dhs's ability to do so fair to
say you mean the qu is it the question
whether this bill will improve our
ability to to provide this transact to
develop continue to promote strategies
to deal with um healthy pregnancies
early childhood and reducing unintended
pregnancies this would improve your
ability Gathering these statistics would
improve your ability to do
that you want this one I thank you for
the question
um certainly as uh you know collecting
data is important to our work I'm not
sure how how it would change what we're
currently doing I mean it would inform
but I'm not sure how we would how would
it be improved what would
be other purposes what what other value
would it have beyond what we've just
talked about collecting the
data um well for us the um the the data
statistics we don't currently collect
those statistics um it's the obviously
ly the legislature's decision whether we
move forward with data collection for
these statistics so uh we don't
currently collect them so I I don't
really have an answer to that one okay
um I just want to
um uh provide more information that uh
we collect data under our legal
Authority so if this bills also um
provide enough legal Authority for DHHS
under hippoc um privacy rules and also
the St statute Etc uh then then we will
be able to um collect the data and then
for the program areas where is internal
external uh who will need to use the
data to make the data more useful so
from the data standpoint that is
something that we have been continue
doing whether it's collecting this uh
data set or other health data set as
well so uh let me just one more followup
you've had three already if you want to
ask another question in a minute I'll
have representative bergon ask a
question fair enough we can get back you
okay I'll be quick thank you very much I
was just curious about the data I don't
know if there are other programs that
you've done this with but do other
departments like make requests from some
of that data is that available to people
or can you just go and look it up or is
that something that we should make a
request for but I'm just curious because
I would probably have a lot of curiosity
on some of that data so uh thank you for
the question so if I uh understand your
question correctly are you asking
whether the abortion data is available
to us uh right now department is not um
collecting the the abortion data so well
I'm just wondering if this was to go
through can other people make requests
with that data or is it guarding um this
will actually fall back to the hipop
reproductive um rules that we will need
to confirm with our uh hipop privacy
officer um so this this is the
information that I gather from our
privacy officer that the the abortion is
now for under reproductive health and
then there is a new Hippa rule that
regulate that part so sorry I do not
have the question uh answer to your
question but we are happy to get back to
you well thank you I'm just glad to know
we have a privacy officer so thanks any
other questions from any other members I
apologize I don't your subs I don't know
what your name okay uh representative
lane lane thank you um uh thank you for
taking my question could you and I just
kind of spaced out you were talking
about there a fiscal note but there is
no fiscal note on this
correct yes thank you uh we were we had
provided a fiscal note on S sp36 in the
senate or we're working on that we were
not requested to um assess this for
fiscal impact but we just included that
information what we thought would we if
this um Amendment were um enacted what
what the cost would be to the department
and we put that in our test
testimony you're
welcome any other
questions representative sh did you want
to follow up I'll pass thanks thank you
seeing none thank you very
much uh Kayla monom do you want to go
now or wait till the end now's good okay
red button red means go yes um thank you
Kayla mon I'm very nice to um be back uh
vice president of public affairs for
Planned Parenthood Northern New England
um so I just want to clarify a couple of
things um I actually put on my pink card
support anap POS because I didn't really
know exactly what I want to say here but
to be clear we do we do oppose this
amendment as
drafted however uh we do not oppose the
underlying concept of this type of data
collection so uh representative Lane
asked earlier what the purpose of this
and we would say that we are fully
recognizing that when we have good
Public Health Data when we have good
when we have good data Imports we get
good Public Health outcomes and if the
purpose of this bill is to create better
Public Health outcomes if we're all in
agreement on that then that is certainly
something that Planned Parenthood would
um be interested in working um on a bill
that would do just that um we are plan
parent is a three-state organization so
we have health centers across Maine
Vermont in New Hampshire we have 15
Health Centers plus teleah health and
our colleagues in Maine and Vermont
already do this so this would not be
something that would be that we would
oppose to be doing because our
colleagues do it uh but they have a
different way of doing it um and we also
provide data to The gutmacher Institute
um which is on your testimony um
representative berson asked if you could
see this data if you wanted to Google
and you go to the G marer Institute and
you wanted to Google um New Hampshire
abortions that number would be there
because we voluntarily provide that
information to them uh we are confident
that they uh we're confident in their
ability to make sure that that data is
collected in a way that is secure and
that there would be no data breaches and
we're confident that what they do with
that information is to benefit public
health so we have no problem providing
that information uh to The gutmacher
Institute and I believe the other
abortion providers in New Hampshire do
the same as well um but of course uh
like all laws the devils in the details
right and I think we can all agree that
when it comes
to Private health care data uh it needs
to be secure and uh we can't be working
on anything that would jeopardize or
compromise safety security or privacy of
patients and also providers
um and we have seen this bill as uh
chairman Lyn mentioned this was from
this is a bill from 2016 so we have seen
it I would say every year maybe every
other year we've seen different versions
of this bill um often it was in a house
HHS um and every year it's gotten a
little bit different we've gotten a
little more comfortable with it we've
worked on it we've made some changes um
this kind of takes us back though so uh
like previous speakers mentioned uh
Senate Bill 36 was heard last week in
the house that is something that we are
we know it's not in final form yet there
is a fiscal Note coming we went in last
week and we made five suggestions to
that particular bill um and I'd be happy
to walk through some of those
suggestions um but for the amendment
that we're looking at today right in
front of us there's um just a couple of
fundamental flaws that I just want to
point out of reasons why we're opposing
this particular bill um one being that
we think the data should be aggregated
and not incident
reporting
um we again because just for privacy
purposes we think that's really
important we don't want um anyone facing
threats of violence no no one wants
wants that no one wants that um and we
talked a little bit about Hippa the
division of Vital Records who I don't
speak for and is not here but um they
don't regularly deal with this type of
uh Healthcare information it's more like
birth and death and um they just don't
that's just not something that they're
that they do
um and uh and I know that Miss Tanner
mentioned that as
well um and then this um one thing
that's uh important to note about and
I'm going to use Maine as an example
because we have health centers there and
I'm familiar with it the way Maine
collects data is they have a secure
online portal so we our providers put
the information directly into the portal
so if DHHS and when they have a uh
fiscal note could create a portal A
system that is hippoc compliant it is
secure it we the providers know exactly
what to do then that would work but this
amendment in front of you doesn't have
um really any information about how that
data is going to be collected so those
are our concerns with this amendment in
front of you but like I said Senate Bill
36 in the house um in the Senate sorry
um is being worked on um and I'd be
happy to offer the five suggestions that
we put in on that bill but I realize
that's not in front of you so um I think
I can pause there and just um you know
reiterate that we are more than happy to
work with you all on
um some type of Bill that gets to a
place where we can all be confident that
this data is being securely inputed and
used for the right reasons um uh but
this bill in front of you uh is
something that we would that we oppose
as written happy to take questions thank
you representative uh Sher um would it
be fair to say that the Senate bill
right now is probably the better vehicle
to accomplish what uh Planned Parenthood
uh cares about in terms of privacy than
this bill as it's currently
written yes and um the sponsor of the
bill said that that bill is not
finalized yet either they're waiting on
their fiscal note and then there's some
areas that they um are looking to clean
up a little bit the the amendment the
sponsor said that it's more of a
placeholder right now but I would agree
that when we're comparing these two
bills side by side which I know you
don't have in front of you but that um
bill would be a better vehicle for
confidentiality thank
you representative pel thank you and
thank you for taking my question you
said that in um that you already report
New Hampshire statistics to gut maler
and if
so how do you report on the aggregate of
abortions that are performed or do you
or do you report based on the type of
abortion that's performed or the um a
age of gation so we report based on what
they ask us to report so they're not
always going to be asking us for the
same thing but we always report in the
aggregate we don't do individualized
incident reporting which is why we feel
it's uh you know a much more secure way
of doing our
reporting yes
followup thank you so to um
representative Lynn's um question or
comment earlier in his
testimony um he thought that possibly we
would be able to differentiate um early
abortion versus late term abortions
would that is you do
not report based on the length of the
term before the abortion is performed
so you I don't know what has been
recently reported but you can go on
gutmacher in Institute website and look
to see if those are you know things that
are being reported but I will say it
this this bill does require gational
reporting
one way that you could make that more
secure is to say an estimated gational
range um so there's a couple of ways
that we could improve that um but if you
know planed Parenthood of course follows
all state and federal laws so if we're
asked to be reported on that we
certainly would but there's ways that we
can make sure that we're not de
identifying patients that is really
important when we live in a small state
that doesn't have a lot of um a lot of
abortion numbers in General and so we
need to make sure that no patient is
being de being reidentified um that is
definitely our priority and I'm and I'm
sure that everyone in this room agrees
that that is a priority as well no one
wants that personal Health Data um being
public are there any other questions for
this witness yeah representative
McFarland further to representative
pel's questions uh let me make sure I
understand before I get to the thrust of
my question am I right in understanding
that when you were talking about the
submissions that you make to the good
marker Institute that you regard those
as deidentified data yes yeah it's
aggregated data yep okay and you you
talked about Maine as an example where
they have a secure online portal as you
put it the submissions that Planned
Parenthood makes in the state of Maine
are they submissions of identified data
or deidentified data um I believe it's
incident reporting so deidentified but
uh so identified however it is it's
secure and it is so Maine has um a state
level CDC so if you drive through
Augusta you'll see the building right
there and it is information that goes to
this like state level CDC which is
hippoc compliant um they've been doing
this for a long time so I don't know
exactly how this came about or why but I
know that they've made some tweaks to it
um in order to ensure more patient
privacy taking away a few um reporting
ing you know things that just weren't
necessary anymore um but there is a
agreement between abortion providers in
the state Dom main that that data is
always going to be secure because they
have this additional level of um of
support through this state level CDC so
am I correct in understanding then that
you're saying that in the case of the
state of
Maine they uh have this secure online
portal which happens to be HP compliant
and therefore can accept identifi data
in the case of the good Market Institute
the reason that you're able to submit
that information is because it is
deidentified and therefore does not fall
under hipper is that right that's
correct thank
you any other questions on this witness
seeing none thank you thank
you Meg and I apologize over B thank you
thank
you
oops thank you um I spoke earlier I'm a
pharmacist in um a three Hospital health
system and I'm a native New Hampshire
resident um and I did just want to voice
my opposition to this amendment um as
it's written I agree that it would
probably be reasonable to collect data
um because the majority plurality of
states do um collect data and send that
to the CDC but I do have concerns about
privacy um I'm not a hip expert but I've
have been adjacent to it it for 20 years
working in healthcare and I will say
that we are very concerned
about um data that can be used to
potentially identify people even though
it seems like it might be um neutral
data such as age because if you have a
patient who's from a very small town and
you require that they record their age
and other features like that data
becomes more likely to be identifiable
um that would be one concern of mine um
also quote the American College of
Obstetricians and gynecologists they are
opposed to any reporting requirements
that are um disproportionate to the risk
and safety of abortion care provision
um so I um don't know that the way the
bill is written that we're going to um
add value to Providers to have to have
them submit monthly into a portal or
some other um submission mechanism and
then I'm not I'm not sure if familiar
representative um if all the other 46
states have this $1,000 penalty for
non-compliance which was a little bit of
a concern of mine as well um I was also
concerned about how this is going to be
getting financed um it's um some
additional administrative burden both
for any Hospital Health Care system or
provider and also the state um in a time
when we have a Statewide hiring freeze
so we have to find funds to create this
portal potentially or whatever mechanism
staff positions to monitor to this data
um so again um not inherently imposed to
better data collection but not in this
format of this Bill thank you thank you
any questions of this witness see
representative uh trip uh thank you
thank you for taking my question
uh I believe you said that uh
depending on the data
requested that it may be I per it may be
possible
to identify the
patient yes um in my experience um again
I'm not a Hipp professional but just in
my experience working in healthcare we
get concerned when you start collecting
granular data about people who would be
potentially from a small population area
if you say this patient was a
25-year-old woman from a town with only
you know 40
people like she could be re could be
reasonably identified in that scenario
that's the kind of scenario that I'd be
concerned about um so like measures like
patient age um I don't know that they
necessarily add value um and again maybe
if like a secure hippo like a fully
hippoc compliant portal would be created
but um I think that will add some time
in an expense that might not have been
considered in this
legislation thank you
representative Morton thank you um and
thank you for speaking
today are there any other health
statistics that are not
reported I'm not an expert in public
health reporting um so I'm like what do
you mean like to whom and about what
what health measures well I mean a few
years ago I mean world meter was a
website it's not part of the CDC it's a
non hippoc compliant website I guess um
and it reported everything about covid
the website still exists talks about
number of people who die every day and
and so forth all kinds of St statistics
like that um the number of flu uh
incidents and deaths and all that that's
reported um I'm just wondering are there
any other health statistics that are not
reported is this like an anomaly is it
by
itself um I think your examples are not
analogous because those are public
health which is a very different um
environment and obviously you know like
abortion is not contagious um so um from
a public health perspective I I um for
example I don't know of a registry like
let's say we create this registry
because we're concerned about
complications right like abortions
generally have a complication rate of 2%
uh a hip or a knee replacement
complication rate could be 2 to 5% so
I'm not aware of any state registry
that's saying oh we need to track every
hip and Joint procedure
for complications um like that's kind of
the an analogy I came up with um so um I
mean there's cancer Registries and like
cancer data out there but
um infectious disease is its own game as
far as like kind of like data reporting
goes in in my experience right and and
when you mention cancer that's I don't
think that's uh contagious either
there's a number of other things that
are reported that are not contagious so
is there a question
I guess I guess the question is is this
by itself aside from the fact that it's
not a contagious uh situation I think
she answered that okay yeah like I don't
I'm not aware of like numbers that get
reported to the state about like how
many patients have diabetes or you know
what I mean um but that is also like not
a particular purview of mine any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you attorney Ian is a
Hoy uh it's Hitt Mr chair but I've heard
every possible
mispronunciation I apologize speaking
for Cornerstone today Cornerstone is the
only full-time Christian advocacy
organization in New Hampshire we work
with an advocate for over a 100 churches
around the state and in this most recent
election Cornerstone endorsed 159
candidates of whom 138 were elected with
only to the bill to the amendment Mr
chair may I speak just giving a
background of his organization I assume
that's all
right I'm speaking on cornerstone's
recommendation as to the committee's
vote on this amendment Mr chair of the
138 candidates that Cornerstone endorsed
with only two or three exceptions
Cornerstone screened for not just
whether people were pro-life in some
abstract theoretical sense where perhaps
Jesus Will enact pro-life policy at the
end of days but whether they would
support specific incremental and
moderate abortion restrictions now some
of those 138 Representatives have
changed their policies many in the last
7 2 hours but nonetheless dozens of
districts voted for candidates they
believed would support moderate abortion
restrictions if not just the 64% of the
state that supports moderate
restrictions but the 10% of the state
that is very strongly pro-life is not
even permitted to lose a floor vote on a
moderate abortion restriction I'm going
to have to ask you at this point are you
speaking about the
amendment about two sentences left Mr
chair yes I am speaking in opposition to
the the amendment thank you uh then the
small r republican process is not
functioning and for that reason I would
ask that if the committee does exec this
bill today it vote in opposition to the
amendment and I would welcome any
questions Mr chair okay thank you any
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank
you last witness I have is uh Courtney
Reid
thank you chair and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Courtney Reid with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and uh I am speaking in
opposition to this amendment uh mostly
for reasons that we've heard from other
speakers uh I just want
to uh restate that in 2016 when
considering the balance of data for
public health use uh and privacy rights
this body did decisively vote down a
very similar Bill and has voted down a
very similar Bill numerous times uh and
with
that uh the Senate right now is
considering a similar
Bill to collect data that uh as we've
heard is a work in progress uh we
provided testimony on that bill with
several of the the concerns that we have
uh however we feel uh in agreement with
the speakers today that that is a better
vehicle that will
uh better address some of the privacy
concerns laid out in the amendment
before us uh I could outline a few of
those um you've heard some of these
concerns from other speakers uh for
example we have a couple of of concerns
about the individualized data uh being
collected um for one uh the lack of
funding to safeguard this data being
protected is certainly at the top of
mind uh wanting to ensure that there is
a system in place to make sure that
there are are limited risks to data
breaches um in addition to that uh we we
do support the uh changes to collect
aggregate data and I would advise
members of this committee or those who
are interested in making adjustments to
the Senate Bill uh as it goes through
the legislative process to also consider
models from Massachusetts and Vermont
which uh prompt aggregate data or uh
data about the um the abortion itself
rather than data about the
patient uh another concern we heard from
dhj during the Senate Bill hearing was
that uh they would like to have some
sort of rul making Authority uh we
talked about considerations of privacy
in rural areas and what data might be
public facing I think giving the
department that discretion um would help
uh dissuade some of these privacy
concerns uh also want to underscore the
concern about having the uh Department
of Vital Statistics be the collector of
data on the front end uh that not being
a hipa protected uh
entity um I could go into a couple other
considerations with this bill but I want
to protect your time um I do want to
note that this bill does have a 91a
exemption that is not in the Senate bill
and that is something that we would be
interested in seeing um should the two
bodies want to continue to collaborate
to uh make the best of this bill go
forward
um I'll just I'll stop there and I'm
open to taking questions thank you so
much are there any questions of this
witness representative
Lane thank you and thanks for typing my
question um so on the
91a are you saying you want it in the
bill or you don't want it in the bill
because I don't want to make assumptions
the 91a exemption thank you for your
question the 91a exemption is something
that we would be open to having
conversations about um including in the
Bill thank you any other
questions seeing none thank
you that's the last speaker I have is
there anyone else who wants to speak on
this
amendment seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on Amendment 2025
31h thank you
so here's what I'd like to do I'm I'd
like us to take a recess for about 15
minutes or so and then um uh I'll deal
with the issue of the executive session
both on this bill and um what I what I
would like to uh specifically want to
talk to the ranking member about is
whether it is possible that we may we
may be able to exact some or perhaps
even all but at least some of the bills
that we now have scheduled to exec on
January 30th I think that there are my
my impression is that there are some
that we would be very much in agreement
on um and I but I'd like to talk to her
about that so why don't we recess and
reconvene at about 215 okay thank
you
e
e e
so I'm going to call uh the Judiciary
Committee back uh to order um and I'm
going to um open the executive session
on uh House Bill 476 and the non-gain
amendment and um I'm happy to hear if
somebody if anybody objects but my very
strong inclination will be that I will
uh immediately recess the executive uh
session Mr chair yes does this come as a
surprise to you I strongly object to
that and let me tell you
why
you
scheduled the
hearing and we were
told that we were going to have a
hearing on the underlying Bill and then
we were going to
exec the underlying bill that was not
quite two weeks ago last I think Tuesday
or maybe it was Wednesday morning the
decision was that there would now be a
non gerain
Amendment added to the bill and that we
would hear it immediately after we
finished at 11:00 the um hearing on uh
the underline bill and we would then
um have a hearing on the on the
amendment and we would then
exec and that was in the calendar and
that is what was what everybody expected
what everybody
understood then in the f of time people
were told although not all of us were
told that the bill was going to
be uh at the request that that the prime
and the mini
primes were um going to um ask that the
bill be
withdrawn however that
bill was assigned to this committee
it was put on the
schedule for today it is in the hands of
the
committee and therefore I believe it is
the committee's decision and um it's all
well and good um for somebody to change
their mind and I don't have any problem
with our clerk wanting to change her
mind for whatever reason and I don't
even a ask why
except that
um meanwhile it's the bill is in our
possession and I think we ought to vote
on the motion ought to be otpa or
itl uh whatever and if it's
otpa then the first thing is we vote on
the amendment maybe the amendment will
pass maybe it won't um I don't prejudge
that and but I care about process and
then we would go to the bill now if the
first motion is itl then there is no no
and that passes then the amendment just
disappears because there's no underlying
bill I do not I cannot
believe that with all the attention
given to this that the speaker really
wants this bill to come to the floor of
the house or that the governor really
wants the bill to come to the floor of
the house and there are few enough times
Well when I can say that I'm surely
going to support the governor I support
the speaker more than that but
um I I think we ought to do what's our
job to do and that's vote on the
bill and I'm
so that's okay no go
on so if we vote on the bill what
happens to the
withdrawal it's mooded
all I beg to
differ Mr chairman um I would have two
questions if I may of of you and
potentially the ranking member first of
all am I right in understanding that
house rule 39e is crystal clear that
once a request to withdraw has been
filed uh that the committee in
possession of the bill is not obligated
to make a recommendation on a bill with
that pending withdrawal request it's not
obligated right
and second of all am I right in
interpreting that rule that even if we
were without obligation to make such a
recommendation the withdrawal request
would still be pending before the house
it doesn't say that does it and it I beg
to differ it it it says that the
withdrawal request which is
pending there's nothing in there that
says that the nature of that pending
request is modified by our making a
recommendation on the bill
anyone I'm happy to hear from anyone
else may want to does that does it
mention in there about have after the
hearing has already opened in regards to
for when the withdrawal is made before
after the said hearing for that bill
well I would think that the chairman
would be better positioned to respond
but I can tell you that what I read here
in in plain language is first of all
that we are also not obligated to have
held the public hearing although we
chose to but to your question if I
understand correctly the request to
withdrawal was filed before we held the
hearing I you know I guess I you know I
guess what I I guess what I would say is
this I I all of these all of these sort
of issues are interesting kind of issues
but I think what is beyond dispute is
that it is my call as to whether or not
are to recess the uh uh to recess the
executive session so um I'm happy to
representative Smith has made her
position uh clear as to why we should
not recess the exe I should not recess
the executive session if anybody else
wants to address that I'm happy to
listen
to thank you Mr chair I just have a
question of you um because I don't know
if you recess the exact do you have to
um recess it to a specific date yes
I do have to do that and do you have in
mind what date that would be yes I do I
would I would I would recess it to
February 19th which would be well after
this bill will go to the floor and I
guess I would say you know in in
response to uh um representative Smith's
point I it seems to me that it is I
could be wrong but it seems to me very
likely that the house will vote um uh to
accept the withdrawal of this bill I
could be wrong but I don't think I am um
but if in some you know really unusual
Circumstance the house did not vote to
do that it would seem to me that
knowing having the result of that vote
not to do that would be something that
would be important for this Committee in
deciding what we would do with the bill
if it came back to us and I you know
that will give us
I I would think if it would give us a
pretty good idea of where what the house
was thinking which would be I think
helpful to us in deciding what to do so
uh I would point it out M I'm sorry no
go ahead I I would point out that if I
am correct you will not be here on the
19th I will not be here on the 19th okay
so um yes representative Manos thank you
Mr thank you Mr
so um if you recess the exact to
February 19th and the house acts on the
uh withdrawal prior to that what happens
to the amendment your propos does it
does the amendment if if the house votes
to withdraw to accept the withdrawal
then both the bill and the amendment
die um anyone else yes representative
tur yeah just process-wise um am I
correct that just as you opened and then
and then am s are suggesting that we uh
postpone the rest of the exec session
could we not have done that this morning
with the hearing overall it was
announced we opened it we could have if
I'm reading it correctly decided to
adjourn that hearing until a later date
when this was all known it feels as and
the reason I asked this is it feels as
though the decision that was made to
hold the hearing today puts us in the
position of now having done all of the
work on on these bills and I would like
to finish that process and not basically
have our all of all that effort
essentially dismissed by a vote of the
house on you know the underlying
withdrawal okay I'm
thinking giving the people the ability
to speak whether it's moot or not is is
is important so whether or not we
execute today or we execute at all or it
gets withdrawn allowing the the public
to speak on the bill and have a voice is
more important than our our time
frames just as a f I agree it was a good
decision I would just like to finish the
process I hear you all right anybody
else have anything they want to say on
on the yes representative sh picking up
on what representative tur said you know
I think it was a good decision to have
the hearings uh and let everyone speak
but um and that was our responsibility
in many ways to do that but I think it's
equally our responsibility to uh express
our opinions at this point rather than
uh uh abdicate uh to a a more Arcane
process all right anyone else wish to be
heard
um I'm I'm just going to make one more
point and then I I'll you know I I would
like to think that I could be persuasive
and or that you could be pers persuaded
I don't know which is and I imagine that
there's lots that I don't know about
what's going on but I believe very
strongly that the work of the
legislature is done in committee it is
not done on the floor of the house the
floor of the house is where we um can
possibly make slight changes or Rectify
a mistake of a committee but it is the
committee's
responsibility we have been here now for
five
hours um and we have people were
attentive people were
respectful um uh the audience was the
best um
behaved I that I can remember in many
many years on on the on this subject
matter and I think that the it is
respectful of the process that the
committee carry out its
responsibilities um and um I I grant you
that you are the chair I grant you that
you have the authority I don't question
that and you know that I
respect you as an individual and because
of your position but I think that the
committee should be respected to two and
that we ought to be able to vote on this
now um I have no idea how the vote will
will turn out and it might be that you
know that people will hang me up to dry
or or if I were one of our colleagues
you know nail me to a tree um but um
that's a bad joke I'm sorry uh and and
that you know the the outcome wouldn't
be what I might have predicted but I
think we ought to know how this
committee feels about the underlying
Bill and and the non-gain amendment and
you make your decision and you have
years of experience of having to make
judicious decisions and I recognize that
but I want to be clear that I think it's
the responsibility of the Judiciary
Committee to handle this matter and I
will
be uh obviously I'm not going you know
what what we would do on the floor I'm
not going
to
oppose the the right of the of the Prime
sponsor to withdraw but this bill was
put in knowing full well that that it
was never going to go ahead that the
governor was not going to support it
that the speaker was not going to
support it it was put in to make a point
and the point was made that there are
people who think that the bill has
credit and I understand that there was
never an expectation that it was going
to pass now I think it's important that
the Judiciary Committee can carry out
its obligations thank you and I'm
finish right representative
Perez can we vote to accept the
withdrawal as being our vote would that
no okay we cannot
anyone else wish to be heard all right
seeing none thank you very much I
appreciate the input I've received from
everybody I'm uh my decision is that I
am going to recess the hearing uh the
executive session on this matter to
February
19th uh at 10:00 a.m. um and as as
representative Smith pointed out I will
not be here but I I'm sure I leave it in
the very capable hands of Vice chairman
Manion I expect I fully expect that
there will be nothing to exec because
there will be nothing left of this bill
by that time it'll it'll having gone to
the floor and having and the withdrawal
having been accepted by the house um
with that I think we're U adjourned and
I will see remember
unfortunately because we couldn't do we
couldn't exact a number of bills that I
think we would have all we would have
had agreement on and at least cut down
if not limited our job on Thursday so
we're going to I'll see you all on
Wednesday for our hearing ings um and
then on Thursday for executive session I
would like to point out that you have
already scheduled starting at 900 a.m.
on the 19th a series of hearings on
bills right and by the time you get one
at 9 one at 9:45 one at
10:30 um and uh so if you've now
announced 10
o' how is that we're going to have to
give I have to do an amended notice I
you know what I by the way that that's
I'm glad actually raise that point um
I'm going to be um just so everybody
knows I'm going to be doing amended
schedules uh for the 5th the 12th and
the 19th and it's not I'm gonna have to
put this in that I just did but just so
you so you know um I'm on the between
the the fifth and the 12th I'm
flipping I'm flipping I'm the the one
bill for another because um the prime
sponsor of a bill that had been
scheduled for the 5th is going to be out
of the country and this is the first
time she's introduced a bill she was
very excited about testifying she seems
like a very nice person and I said fine
I'm going to switch the time uh so that
her bill will be heard on the 12th and
I'm moving a bill up from the 12th to
the 5th and for the 19th repes
representative Manion pointed out that I
I had scheduled for the last hearing of
the day on that day one of the the bill
on the uh
uh uh
transgender Sports and bathroom the bill
it was last year 396 from last year he
points out correctly that that could end
up taking some time so I'll move that up
I'll move that up earlier in the day um
and uh uh and that's going to be the
change so I'm incorporate this change
into
that uh the uh yes that's where we had
it last time 396 we had it in here last
time and there you know it's it's
crowded but not
uh maybe
maybe all right um anything
else but uh well for you don't I mean if
you're going to have executive sessions
you'll you'll but I don't I mean it's up
to yeah I don't know that you I don't
know that you will it's up that'll be up
to why don't you wait until you well I
could that's what I'm saying I mean
that's what I had kind of that's what I
was kind of thinking but do it
for yeah I mean we're gonna be that's
we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna be
busy that we're gonna be busy that first
week in March for sure yeah but I guess
you know I what I would say is if it
turn if you have bills if you have bills
during the time you know that you're
that it looks like everybody's it's not
going to be a controver controversial go
you know and you got unanimous or almost
unanimous
this to do this We're not gonna have to
do it it'll be it'll be dead it'll be
dead all right thank you everyone